This is the 99% of visible breakdown of the Constitution. I'm Roman Mars. And I'm Elizabeth Joe. Today we are discussing Article 4, which talks about the relationship between the states and between the states and the federal government. We're also skipping ahead a bit and adding the 10th Amendment to this conversation because that also talks about the states. Our guest for this episode is California Attorney General Rob Bonta. State attorneys general provide legal counsel to their state's government, oversee state prosecutions, and represent the public. interest in a variety of cases. They also have the responsibility of protecting their state's citizens
这里是对宪法可见部分的99%的拆解。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我是伊丽莎白·乔。今天我们讨论第四条，它探讨了各州之间以及各州与联邦政府之间的关系。我们还稍微向前跳跃了一下，将第十修正案加入到这次对话中，因为该修正案也涉及各州。我们本期的嘉宾是加利福尼亚州总检察长罗布·邦塔。州总检察长为本州政府提供法律顾问服务，监督州内起诉，并在各种案件中代表公众利益。他们还肩负着保护本州公民的职责
from federal overreach. What constitutes an overreach can vary widely depending on the state's political leaning and who's in control of the federal government. During the Obama and Biden administrations, red states sued the federal government over issues like Medicaid expansion and environmental regulations. Now, blue states like California have sued the Trump administration dozens of times for things like withholding federal funding and deploying the National Guard without consent of the state. Attorney General Bonta talks about some of these lawsuits and why he believes the Constitution is on his side.
免受联邦政府权力的过度扩张。什么构成权力的过度扩张，会根据各州的政治倾向以及联邦政府的掌控者而有很大差异。在奥巴马和拜登政府时期，红色州曾就医疗补助扩大和环境法规等问题起诉联邦政府。现在，像加利福尼亚这样的蓝色州已经几十次起诉特朗普政府，原因包括扣留联邦资金以及在未经州政府同意的情况下部署国民警卫队。总检察长邦塔谈到了其中一些诉讼，以及他为什么认为宪法站在他这一边。
But first, Elizabeth takes us through what we need to know about Article 4 and the 10th Amendment. Okay, so unlike Articles 1, 2, and 3, which we've already talked about, they set up the federal government and get a lot of attention. Article 4 does not get too much love. Most people have no idea what it's about. It's not thought of too often.
但首先，伊丽莎白将带我们了解关于第四条和第十修正案我们需要知道的内容。好的，与我们已经讨论过的第一、二、三条设置联邦政府并获得大量关注不同，第四条并没有得到太多的关爱。大多数人根本不知道它是关于什么的。人们不太经常想到它。
But it is an important source of powers and protections for the states. So when we talk about the relationship between the federal government and that of the states, we refer to that structure as federalism. And we've talked about federalism lots of times. Yeah. But maybe we could really call that vertical federalism. Okay. So there's a, well, that's because it's the federal government sort of how it relates to each one of the 50 states.
但它是各州权力和保护的重要来源。所以当我们讨论联邦政府与各州政府之间的关系时，我们将这种结构称为联邦制。而且我们已经多次讨论过联邦制了。是的。但也许我们真的可以把这叫做垂直联邦制。好吧。所以有一个，嗯，这是因为它是联邦政府以及它与50个州中每一个州的关系。
But the states have relationships with one another, and sections one and two of Article 4 are actually about the relationships among the states. And we can talk about that as horizontal federalism. Got it. Got it. Yeah. So why don't we start with Section 1? Roman, why don't you read Section 1? Okay.
但各州之间也彼此存在关系，第四条的第一款和第二款实际上就是关于各州之间的关系的。我们可以将其称为水平联邦制。明白了。明白了。是的。那我们为什么不从第一款开始呢？罗曼，你为什么不读一下第一款？好的。
Full faith and credit shall be given in each state to the public acts, records, and judicial proceedings of every other state. And Congress may, by general laws, prescribe the manner in which. which such acts, records, and proceedings shall be proved and the effect thereof. All right. That's a mouthful. So section one is also known as the full faith and credit clause. And the full faith and credit clause embodies the idea that we need some kind of interstate cooperation in our system for the system to work. And the basic idea with the full faith and credit clause is that the states are supposed to respect the laws, records, and court decisions of other states. That's the general idea.
各州应对每一其他州的公共法案、记录和司法程序给予充分的信任和尊重。国会可以通过一般法律规定此类法案、记录和程序应如何被证明及其效力。好的。这可真是一段拗口的话。所以第一款也被称为充分信任和尊重条款。而充分信任和尊重条款体现了这样一种理念：为了使我们的体制运转，我们的体制中需要某种州际合作。充分信任和尊重条款的基本思想是，各州应该尊重其他州的法律、记录和法院判决。这就是总体的概念。
Yeah, yeah. Well, what it means in the specifics, however, is that if, for instance, you have a state court issue a judgment in your favor, let's say you win a case and the court awards you damages or money, you can ask a court in another state to enforce or respect that judgment. Let's say if the person who owes you money now has left the state and taken their assets with them. The defendant doesn't get another chance to redo the case just because the dispute is essentially traveled to another state. Got it. That's really what the clause is about.
对，对。然而，具体而言，这意味着如果，例如，你有一个州法院作出了有利于你的判决，假设你赢得了一起官司，法院判给你损害赔偿金或金钱，你可以要求另一个州的法院执行或尊重该判决。比方说，如果欠你钱的人现在已经离开了该州并把他们的资产也带走了。被告不能仅仅因为争议本质上转移到了另一个州，就获得另一次机会来重审这个案件。明白了。这才是该条款的真正含义。
Yeah. Most of the time, though, the full faith and credit clauses mostly overlooked. It doesn't feel like a hot topic, right? Yeah. Well, I think it's sort of metabolized into our way of being. Like, I don't think that I'd have different rights in different states necessarily all that much. I just think of the United States as one big thing, which is kind of how this works in practice.
不过，大多数时候，充分信任和尊重条款基本上都被忽视了。它感觉不像是一个热门话题，对吧？是的。嗯，我认为它已经融入了我们的生活方式中。比如，我不认为我在不同的州会有非常大的不同权利。我只是把美国看作一个整体，这在实践中其实就是这样运作的。
That's the way it's supposed to work in theory. But there are a few areas where there have been some. important questions, and actually one of them is marriage. So in 2015, the Supreme Court decided the case of Obergefell v. Hodges, and that's the case in which the Supreme Court recognized a constitutionally protected right to same-sex marriage, right? And so there had been a longstanding constitutionally protected right to marriage before the Obergefell case, but it wasn't until 2015 that the Supreme Court formally recognized that this right. also included the LGBTQ community.
这就是它在理论上应该运作的方式。但有几个领域出现过一些重要问题，其中之一其实就是婚姻。所以在2015年，最高法院对奥贝格费尔诉霍奇斯案作出了裁决，这就是最高法院承认同性婚姻受宪法保护的权利的那个案件，对吧？所以在奥贝格费尔案之前，长期以来一直存在着受宪法保护的结婚权利，但直到2015年，最高法院才正式承认这项权利也包括LGBTQ群体。
So that raises the question. Well, what was life like before Oberfell? It's hard to remember. Yeah, it's hard to remember. But the answer is that whether or not any state recognized same-sex marriages, whether the marriage occurred within the state or without the state,
这就提出了一个问题。那么，在奥贝格费尔案之前的生活是怎样的？这很难回忆起来。是的，很难回忆起来。但答案是，无论任何州是否承认同性婚姻，无论婚姻发生在州内还是州外，
was often up to question and left up to individual states. So some states, if you recall these before times, some states recognize same-sex marriage, but other states didn't, and in fact they went further and either passed laws or changed even their state constitutions to say that marriage was only between a man and a woman within that state. But of course, at the same time, there was a growing movement for marriage equality to recognize that same-sex couples had rights to marriage. So what if you were part of a same-sex couple, lawfully married in one state, but then moved to a state where same-sex marriage was not legal, right?
往往都是个疑问，并留给各州自行决定。所以有些州，如果你还记得这些过去的时代，有些州承认同性婚姻，但其他州不承认，事实上它们走得更远，通过了法律甚至修改了各自的州宪法，规定在该州内婚姻只能在男人和女人之间进行。但当然，与此同时，争取婚姻平权的运动日益高涨，要求承认同性伴侣拥有结婚的权利。那么，如果你是同性伴侣的一部分，在一个州合法结婚，但随后搬到了同性婚姻非法的州，会怎么样呢？
So prior to 2015, the answer wasn't really clear at all, because on the one hand, it's actually not clear that it's answered by the full faith and credit clause for complicated reasons, but let me just put it this way. On the one hand, a marriage isn't really a judgment. That's the language of the clause itself. A marriage is really a civil contract between two people, right? The court doesn't judge that you're married. No court does that.
所以在2015年之前，答案一点也不明确，因为一方面，由于复杂的原因，其实并不清楚这是否可以通过充分信任和尊重条款来解答，但让我这样说吧。一方面，婚姻其实不是一项判决。那是该条款本身的措辞。婚姻实际上是两个人之间的一份民事合同，对吧？法院并没有裁决你们结婚了。没有任何法院会这样做。
And then second, courts allowed what's called a public policy exception to the full faith and credit clause. So even if we agreed that a marriage was a judgment, which is a question, it really could be the case that a state court would say, well, it's against the public policy of our state to recognize same-sex marriage. And then the court might decline to do so. And in 1996, Congress went even further and passed what was called the Defense of Marriage Act or DOMA. Right. I don't know if you remember that. I do remember that. Yeah. And then one of the significant things that DOMA did was to allow states to refuse to recognize same-sex marriages, even if these marriages were finalized in states where that marriage was actually illegal. Okay. So how could Congress do that?
然后第二，法院允许对充分信任和尊重条款实行所谓的公共政策例外。因此，即使我们同意婚姻是一项判决（这是一个问题），州法院也完全有可能说，承认同性婚姻违背了我们州的公共政策。然后法院可能会拒绝这样做。而在1996年，国会走得更远，通过了所谓的《捍卫婚姻法案》或DOMA。对。我不知道你是否还记得。我确实记得。对。DOMA的重要作用之一，就是允许各州拒绝承认同性婚姻，即使这些婚姻是在那些同性婚姻实际上合法的州最终确定的。好吧。那国会怎么能这样做呢？
Well, because of the full faith and credit clause. Because the clause itself doesn't just say states have to respect each other's judgments. It happens to give Congress a source of lawmaking power. It's called the effects clause. Right? So the full faith and credit clause allows Congress to prescribe the manner in which such acts, recordings, and proceedings shall be proved and the effect thereof. So it's actually not just saying, hey, states, you have to respect other states' judgments. It's actually a source of federal legislative authority. So with DOMA, it becomes legal for states to refuse to recognize otherwise legal same-sex marriages. And while many states legalized discrimination against same-sex marriages, other states also began to recognize rights. So Massachusetts became the first state to legalize same-sex marriage in 2004, and that's 11 years before the Obergefell decision in the Supreme Court, and many states followed, but many states did not. And then the Supreme Court did decide the case in 2015.
嗯，因为充分信任和尊重条款。因为该条款本身不仅说各州必须尊重彼此的判决。它恰好赋予了国会立法权的来源。这被称为效力条款。对吧？所以充分信任和尊重条款允许国会规定此类法案、记录和程序应如何证明及其效力。所以它实际上不仅仅是在说，嘿，各州，你们必须尊重其他州的判决。它实际上是联邦立法权的一个来源。因此，通过DOMA，各州拒绝承认原本合法的同性婚姻变得合法了。虽然许多州将对同性婚姻的歧视合法化，但其他州也开始承认相关权利。因此，马萨诸塞州在2004年成为第一个将同性婚姻合法化的州，这比最高法院的奥贝格费尔裁决早了11年，许多州随后效仿，但也有许多州没有效仿。然后最高法院确实在2015年作出了该案的裁决。
There, the Supreme Court said that same-sex couples have a fundamental right to marry in all states. So what is the effect of Obergefell and why should we care about this? anymore now that that's sort of settled. Okay. Well, on the one hand, the Supreme Court case does basically invalidate every state law that refused to recognize same-sex marriage. Yeah. After the Obergefell decision, every state has to recognize the right to same-sex marriage because of the Supreme Court's decision.
在那里，最高法院表示同性伴侣在所有州都拥有基本的结婚权利。那么奥贝格费尔案的影响是什么，既然这已经算尘埃落定，为什么我们还要关心这个？好吧，一方面，最高法院的案子基本上否定了每一个拒绝承认同性婚姻的州法律。是的。在奥贝格费尔裁决之后，由于最高法院的裁决，每个州都必须承认同性婚姻的权利。
It's constitutionalized this particular right to marry. And Obergefell also invalidates DOMA, the federal law. That law also is no longer good law. because why it interferes with a constitutionally protected right to marry. But instead of just saying this is like, well, it's interesting background material who cares? Well, in 2022, the Supreme Court decided to unrecognize the constitutionally protected right to an abortion in Dobbs versus Jackson Women's Health Organization. And that case overturned the right that was first recognized in Roe in 1973. And even though abortion might seem to be pretty distinct from marriage, and of course it is a different topic, it was not a different topic for Justice Thomas.
它将这项特定的结婚权利宪法化了。而且奥贝格费尔案也废除了联邦法律DOMA。那项法律也不再是良好的法律了，因为为什么它干预了受宪法保护的结婚权利。但我们不应仅仅认为这像是一个“好吧，这只是有趣的背景材料，谁在乎呢”，在2022年，最高法院在“多布斯诉杰克逊妇女健康组织案”中决定取消对堕胎权的宪法保护。该案推翻了1973年在“罗伊案”中首次确立的权利。尽管堕胎看起来可能与婚姻截然不同，而且它当然是一个不同的主题，但对于托马斯大法官来说，它并非一个不同的主题。
Justice Thomas joined the majority opinion in the Dobbs case, but he also wrote a separate opinion because he had more to say. And essentially his more to say was, look, if we're overturning the right to an abortion, which I think is a good idea, that's his thinking, we might also reconsider some rights. based on the same interpretation that the court issues today. And he calls out specifically Obergefell v. Hodges. Like, maybe we should think about overturning that case. So his opinion set off alarms, as you can imagine. And so the idea here is, look, if Justice Thomas can just convince four other justices that he's right, then presumably that right might be in question.
托马斯大法官加入了多布斯案多数派意见，但他还撰写了一份单独的意见，因为他有更多的话要说。他要说的大意基本上是：看，如果我们正在推翻堕胎权（我认为这是一个好主意——这是他的想法），我们可能也应该根据法院今天发布的相同解释重新考虑一些权利。他特别点名了奥贝格费尔诉霍奇斯案。比如，也许我们应该考虑推翻那个案子。正如你所想象的，他的意见引发了警报。这里的想法是，看，如果托马斯大法官能够说服其他四位大法官他是对的，那么据推测，这项权利可能会受到质疑。
So you said alarm bells went off, but, like, did anything actually come of that? Well, in 2022, this was the Biden administration. President Biden signed the Respect for Marriage Act, or RIFMA. Okay. So what does RIFMA do? So RIFMA formally repeals the Defense of Marriage Act from 1996, right? But it also goes further. One section of RIFMA, this is the federal law, requires all states to give what the law calls full faith and credit to marriages, including same-sex marriages, which, identify specifically if they are lawfully performed within a state. So RIFMA doesn't require a state to license same-sex marriages. In other words, it doesn't require a state that isn't, you know, hadn't done that before to do it. But as long as there is one state in the United States that does
所以你说警报拉响了，但是，有什么实质性的结果吗？嗯，在2022年，当时是拜登政府。拜登总统签署了《尊重婚姻法案》（RFMA）。好的。那么RFMA的作用是什么？所以RFMA正式废除了1996年的《捍卫婚姻法案》，对吧？但它还走得更远。RFMA（这是一项联邦法律）的一个章节要求所有州给予法律所谓的对婚姻的“充分信任和尊重”，包括同性婚姻，特别是明确指出如果它们是在某个州合法缔结的话。所以RFMA并不要求一个州去颁发同性婚姻执照。换句话说，它不要求一个以前没有这么做的州去这么做。但是，只要美国有一个州确实颁发同性婚姻执照，
license same-sex marriages, the effect of RIFMA, this federal law, means that those marriages should be respected in the other 49. And remember, marriage as a legal idea is really important. Of course, it's important symbolically, but it carries all kinds of effects of inheritance, the ability to visit your spouse while they're ill, all kinds of things, the rights over children, things like that. It's extremely important, right? And keep in mind that RIFMA is essentially responding to this threat from one justice on the court, right, because of that. So is the reason why Congress can pass this law? Is it still related to the Congress may, by general laws, the effect clause, all that sort of stuff? Is that part of it?
这项联邦法律RFMA的效力意味着，这些婚姻在其他49个州也应该受到尊重。记住，作为法律概念的婚姻非常重要。当然，它在象征意义上很重要，但它带来了各种继承方面的效力、在配偶生病时探视的权利、各种有关孩子的权利等等。这极其重要，对吧？并且请记住，RFMA本质上是为了回应法院中一位大法官的这种威胁，正因为如此。那么国会能够通过这项法律的原因是什么？它仍然与“国会可以通过一般法律”、效力条款以及所有这类东西有关吗？这是其中的一部分吗？
Exactly right. It's the same reason as DOMA. Congress is relying on the effects clause, the power given to it, under that portion of Article 4. So right now, RFMA doesn't mean too much because Urbvrefell is the law of the land, right? But if for some reason, let's hope not, the Supreme Court were to overturn that decision from 2015, I would expect that we'd see legal fights about the meaning of RFMA and whether Congress actually has the authority. to have passed it in the first place. So that's kind of a sneaky way that we might see the full faith and credit clause come up in some future instance. And that is why full faith and credit is pretty interesting.
完全正确。原因和DOMA一样。国会依据的是效力条款，即第四条那一部分赋予它的权力。所以现在，RFMA并没有太大意义，因为奥贝格费尔案是全国通行的法律，对吧？但如果出于某种原因（但愿不会），最高法院推翻了2015年的那项裁决，我预计我们会看到关于RFMA含义的法律斗争，以及国会最初是否真的拥有通过该法的权力。所以这是一种潜移默化的方式，我们可能会在未来的某个实例中看到充分信任和尊重条款再次出现。这就是为什么充分信任和尊重条款相当有趣。
Yeah. It's also, it's notable that they use that term in the law, full faith and credit, right? To harken back to this. Like, it's saying like, if you're wondering what the constitutional basis for this is, just like follow the words. Yeah, that's exactly right.
是的。值得注意的是，他们在法律中使用了这个词，即“充分信任和尊重”，对吧？以此来呼应这一点。就像是在说，如果你想知道这背后的宪法依据是什么，那就遵循这些字面意思。是的，完全正确。
And part of that is because, you know, it's pretty clear as a concept that, if you have something, and again, assuming that marriage is something that is one of the things called out by the full faith and credit clause, that is protected by that clause, Congress should be able to say, hey, states, you recognize it in one state, then every state has to recognize the same thing. You'll notice what RIFMA is not doing. It is not saying there is a federally protected right to same-sex marriage, because it's not super clear that Congress has the ability to do that. And presumably, you know, Congress and President Biden were just didn't really want to go there. So they kind of took a compromise. measure here with full faith and credit. Got it. Makes sense. Interesting. All right. So next, Section 2, Article 4. Section 2 is a collection of different state issues. So the first clause tells us that the citizens of each state shall be entitled to all privileges and immunities of citizens in the several
部分原因在于，你知道，作为一个概念，它非常明确：如果你有某种东西，再次假设婚姻是充分信任和尊重条款所涵盖的事项之一，且受到该条款的保护，国会应该能够说，嘿，各州，你们在一个州承认了它，那么每个州都必须承认相同的事物。你会注意到RFMA没有做什么。它没有说存在一个联邦保护的同性婚姻权利，因为国会是否拥有这样做的能力并不是超级明确。据推测，你知道，国会和拜登总统只是不想涉足这一领域。所以他们在这里采取了一种折衷措施，通过充分信任和尊重条款来处理。明白了。有道理。很有趣。好的。那么接下来，第四条第二款。第二款是关于不同州级事务的集合。因此第一款告诉我们，每个州的公民应享有各州公民在各州的所有特权和豁免权。
states. So, I mean, think of this as an anti-discrimination principle. The clause prevents states from discriminating against citizens from other states in favor of their own. So that's true for many, but not all situations. Some of the most important legal cases here have focused on things like state residency requirements, that you have to live in a state for a certain time to receive some kind of benefit. And states usually can't interfere with what are considered fundamental rights that are recognized under the privileges and immunities clause. A good example is that the Supreme Court has said, you know, your right to pursue an occupation is something that's protected by this clause. But states do have some latitude.
所以，我的意思是，把这看作是一个反歧视原则。该条款防止各州为了偏袒自身公民而歧视来自其他州的公民。这适用于许多但并非所有的情况。这里一些最重要的法律诉讼集中在诸如州居住要求之类的事情上，即你必须在一个州居住一定时间才能获得某种福利。而且各州通常不能干涉特权和豁免权条款下所承认的被认为是基本权利的事物。一个很好的例子是，最高法院曾表示，你追求某种职业的权利是受该条款保护的东西。但各州确实有一定的自由度。
They can discriminate against out-of-staters for important reasons. That's why you can't go to another state and just say, hey, I have the right to vote in your election. You can't because the state has a good reason to keep voters only to the people who are within the state. Wow. So this part of Article 4 isn't too much in dispute. It's not very controversial. Next, the second clause here, which says a person charged in any state with treason, felony, or other, crime who shall flee from justice and be found in another state shall on demand of the executive
出于重要原因，他们可以歧视州外人员。这就是为什么你不能去另一个州然后说，嘿，我有权在你们的选举中投票。你不能这样做，因为该州有充分的理由将选民限制在州内人员。哇。所以第四条的这部分并没有引起太多争议。它不是很有争议。接下来是这里的第二款，其中规定：任何州被指控犯有叛国罪、重罪或其他罪行的人，逃避司法追究并在另一个州被发现，经他所逃离的州的行政长官要求，应被引渡交出，以便移交给对该罪行有管辖权的州。这被称为引渡条款，它适用于一个人在一个州被指控犯罪然后逃往另一个州的情况。因此，引渡条款承认，一个州的州长可以要求另一个州将此人强制遣返回去。同样，这并没有太大争议，但这再次向我们展示了第四条的另一个方面，即它关乎要求、鼓励、确保各州彼此友好相处，因为这才是体制应该运行的方式，而不是各州相互争斗、歧视彼此的公民，或者在刑事司法等某些重要事情上不予合作。是的，这说得通。所以第三款，也就是逃奴条款。
authority of the state from which he fled be delivered up to be removed to the state having jurisdiction of the crime. This is known as the extradition clause and it applies when a person is accused of a crime in one state and then flees to another. So the extradition clause recognizes that the governor of one state can demand from the other state that the person be forcibly sent back. Again, it's not too controversial, but again, this should, shows us another aspect in which Article 4 is about requiring, encouraging, making sure that the states play nice with one another, because that's how the system should be run, instead of the states fighting against each other, discriminating against each other's citizens, or just not cooperating in some important things like criminal justice. Yeah, that makes sense. So third clause, and that is the fugitive slave clause.
是的。从某种意义上说，我们实际上不需要讨论这个条款，该条款允许奴隶主跨越州界抓捕逃亡的被奴役者，去法院证明所有权，然后获得法律授权，带着被奴役者回到他们的家乡州。你知道的，由于废除奴隶制的第十三修正案，这个条款的整个方面都已经无关紧要了。但我认为我们应该在这里停顿片刻，只是想指出，这只是我们的政府组织文件这一现行根本文件中又一个提到奴隶制的例子。这只是又一个例子。
Yes. So in a sense, we don't really need to talk about this clause, which allowed a slave owner to cross state lines. seize the fugitive enslaved person go to court to prove ownership and then receive legal authorization to go back to their home state with the enslaved person. You know, the entire aspect of this clause is irrelevant because of the 13th Amendment, which abolishes slavery. But I thought we'd pause here for a moment just to note that this is just another instance in which our foundational current document that organizes our government has a reference to slavery. It's just one more.
然而它甚至没有直接提及，对吧？逃奴条款甚至没有使用“奴隶”这个词。它指的是在某一个州被扣留以提供劳务或劳役、并逃到另一个州的人。尽管在当时，所有人都明白这个引用指的就是被奴役的人，而且仅仅是被奴役的人。对，对。所以，你知道，在这里你拥有宪法中的这种历史标记，它不再具有任何法律效力，但它提醒了我们该文件本身非常存在缺陷的起源。
And yet it doesn't even do so directly, right? The fugitive slave clause doesn't even use the word slave. It refers to a person held to serve or labor in one state escaping into another. Although at the time, everyone understood that this reference was to enslave people and enslaved people only. Yeah. Yeah. So, you know, here you have this kind of historical marker in the Constitution that has no legal effect anymore, but it reminds us of kind of the very flawed origins of the document itself.
对，对。据推测，它被明确放在这里是因为某些拥有奴隶的州只是将其作为成为宪法一部分、并同意签署该宪法的必要条件。对。再说一次，我的意思是，这也是另一个有趣的事情。它恰好反映了这样一个事实：该文件本身并非理想化的产物。它是政治妥协的结果。是的。
Right, right. And presumably it was put it here explicitly because certain slave-owning states just required it for it to be part of the Constitution for them to sign on to it. Right. And again, I mean, that's another interesting thing, too. It just reflects the fact that the document itself is not an idealized one. It's the result of political compromise. Yeah.
是的。所以，我的意思是，这是该文件某种程度上根深蒂固的一部分。我们无法回避这样一个事实，即它有着非常，你知道的，再次强调，充满缺陷的起源。是的，是的。但希望，你知道的，但在某些方面，我们通过拥有第十三修正案摆脱了它。这就是修正案的目的所在。没错。让我们继续讨论第三款。第四条第三款有两个部分。第一部分包括加入新州条款。这就是我们如何允许或接纳新州加入联邦的方式。
Yeah. So, I mean, this is sort of the baked-in part of the document. We can't escape the fact that it has this. very, you know, again, flawed origin here. Yeah, yeah. But hopefully, you know, but in some ways, we escaped it by having the 13th Amendment. So that's what amendments are for. That's right. Let's move right along to Section 3. And Section 3 of Article 4 has two parts. The first part includes the admissions clause. And that is how we allow or admit new states to the union.
所以，罗曼，你想读一下那个条款吗？它挺有意思的。当然。国会可接纳新州加入本联邦。但不得在任何其他州的管辖范围内组建或建立任何新州，也不得由两个或多个州或州的一部分合并组建任何州，除非经有关州的立法机关以及国会的同意。好的。这可真是一段拗口的话。但本质上，它是关于新州如何成为美国的一部分的。所以这部分正式允许国会在有一些限制的情况下承认新州成为国家的一部分，正如你刚刚阅读的文本所指出的那样。
So, Roman, you want to read that clause? It's sort of interesting. Sure. New states may be admitted by the Congress. into this union. But no new states shall be formed or erected within the jurisdiction of any other state, nor any state be formed by the junction of two or more states or parts of states without the consent of the legislatures of the states concerned as well as of Congress. All right. That's a mouthful. But essentially, it's how do new states become part of the United States? So this part formally allows Congress to recognize new states to become part of the country with some limitations. as the text you just read points out.
因此，如果一个州是由一个新州组建的，你需要受影响的州的同意，就像肯塔基州在1792年通过分割弗吉尼亚州的一部分而成为一个州时那样。所以这部分似乎合情合理。你不会希望在没有该州同意的情况下切掉该州的一部分。没错。
So if a state is formed from a new state, you need the consent of the affected state, like when Kentucky became a state by taking a part of Virginia in 1792. So that part seems to make sense. You don't want to chop off a part of the state without the state agreeing to do it. That's right.
虽然第三款本身没有提到，但最高法院对加入新州条款进行了阐述，称其具有所谓的“平等地位原则”。因此这个想法很简单，即一个新州，如果它要成为美国的一部分并被国会接纳加入美国，它必须以与现有州平等的条件被接纳。你不会拥有类似次要地位的州。没错。你就像是没有经历试用期一样。完全正确。所以，你知道，法院已经说过它不在其中，但我们假设这是加入新州条款结构中隐含的意思。我喜欢这样。第三款的第二部分包含所谓的财产条款，
And while it's not mentioned in Section 3 itself, the Supreme Court has interpreted the admissions clause to have what it calls an equal footing doctrine. And so the idea is a pretty simple one, that a new state, if it's going to be part of the United States and is admitted to the United States by Congress, it has to be admitted on equal terms as the existing ones. You don't have like a secondary status state. Right. You're not like going through a probationary period. Exactly. Right. So, you know, the court has said it's not in there, but we assume that that's meant in the structure of the admissions clause. I like it. And the second part of Section 3 has what's called the proper.
国会有权处置和制定有关属于美国的领土或其他财产的所有必要的规则和条例。现在，这一部分赋予了国会广泛的权力，对联邦政府拥有的土地采取各种行动。该条款还提到了领土，这也很有趣，因为我们的许多州都是在首先成为领土之后才成为州的，比如阿拉斯加或夏威夷。尽管加入新州条款没有要求，但国会有时曾要求拟议中的州在被允许成为州之前满足某些条件。
Clause, Congress has the power to dispose of and make all needful rules and regulations respecting the territory or other property belonging to the United States. Now, this part gives Congress broad authority to take all kinds of actions over the land the federal government possesses. And the clause also mentions territories, which is interesting too, because many of our states have become states after having been a territory first, like Alaska or Hawaii. And even though the admissions clause doesn't require it, Congress has sometimes required a proposed state to meet some conditions before it's allowed to become a state.
你知道犹他州必须同意才能成为州的条件是什么吗？没有重婚？嗯，没有一夫多妻制，对。没有一夫多妻制，对，对。因此，国会允许犹他州成为州的授权法案实际上要求该州禁止一夫多妻制。更有趣的是，根据其自身宪法的条款，犹他州不允许实行一夫多妻制，除非不仅是犹他州，而且国会也同意。换句话说，国会非常担心该州可能会在这一问题上一夫多妻制到疯狂的地步。他们就像是，除非我们允许，否则你们甚至不能在这个问题上修改你们的州宪法。有趣。
Do you know about the condition that Utah had to agree to becoming a state? No bigamy? Well, no polygamy, right. No polygamy, right, right. So the enabling act by Congress that allowed Utah to become a state actually required the state to ban polygamy. And what's even more interesting is that Utah is not allowed by the terms of its own constitution to allow polygamy unless not just Utah, but Congress agree. In other words, Congress was so worried that the state might just go crazy with polygamy. They were like, you can't even change your state constitution unless we let you on this subject. Interesting.
是的。所以国会绝对可以做到这一点。如果他们对一个拟议中的州有什么不喜欢的地方，他们可以说，除非你们做了这件特定的事情，否则你们不允许成为俱乐部的成员。是的，好的。所以，假设如果我们要做类似的事情，你知道，吞并格陵兰岛——我不赞同这个想法。但如果我们真的那样做了，据推测，途径将是，国会首先赋予它
Yeah. So Congress can definitely do that. If there's something that they don't like about a proposed state, they can say you're not allowed to be a member of the club unless you do. this particular thing. Yeah, okay. So, hypothetically, if we were to do something like, you know, annex Greenland, not endorsing the idea. But if we were to do that, presumably, the path would be, Congress would give it the status
美国领土的地位，对吧？这赋予了它根据财产条款监管该领土的绝对权力。然后它可能最终会成为一个州。如果它确实这样做了，它当然可以要求格陵兰岛达成某种协议，即他们不会做某事或积极去做某事以便成为一个州。尽管我们当然也有一些领土，你知道的，比如波多黎各，当然，它们长期以来一直保持着领土地位，尽管肯定有很多人希望看到波多黎各成为第51个州。所以宪法的这一部分为领土或获得的土地何时可以加入美国设定了基本规则。但它并没有设定那么多的基本规则。
of an American territory first, right, which gives it free reign to regulate the territory under the property clause. And then maybe it would become a state eventually. And if it did so, it could certainly require Greenland to enter into some kind of agreement that they would not do something or do something affirmatively in order to become a state. Although we certainly have territories, you know, like Puerto Rico, of course, that have remained a territory for a very long time, even though there are certainly lots of folks who would like to see Puerto Rico become the 51st state. So this is the part of the Constitution that kind of sets the ground rules for when a territory or an acquire. piece of land can join the United States. But it doesn't set that many ground rules.
它只是说他们可以制定基本规则，但规则可能会根据你所讨论的州而有所不同。是的，本质上这有点留给国会决定。就像他们对该做什么做出政治决策一样。而且我甚至想不出格陵兰岛文化中有什么是国会可能会强加条件的令人反感的东西。但是，是的，没有什么能上升到犹他州问题那种程度的东西。没错。
It just says that they can make the ground rules, but the rules could change depending on what state you're talking about. Yeah, essentially it's kind of left up to Congress. Like they make the political decisions about, you know, what to do. And I can't even think of what would be objectionable in Greenland's culture that Congress might impose conditions. But, yeah, nothing that rises to the level of the Utah issue. Right.
嗯，可能就像，我的意思是，以波多黎各为例，那里有很多复杂的事情。波多黎各有一种涉外和内部的复杂感觉。其中很大一部分与以下事实有关：是的，你目前处于什么政治时刻，这看起来会倾向于一个政党还是另一个政党？这似乎就是它的根源，至少在美国是这样。是的。我的意思是，这确实很有趣，因为宪法确实设想美国可以不断生长、生长、再生长。
Well, it just could be like the, I mean, in the case of Puerto Rico, It's like there's lots of complicated things there. And there's sort of like a class of foreign and domestic sense that Puerto Rico has. And a lot of that has to do with just like, yeah, where you are politically at this moment, does it seem like it's going to favor one political party or another? And that sort of seems to be the source of it, at least in the United States. Yeah. I mean, it is interesting, though, because the Constitution does contemplate that the United States can grow and grow and grow.
对此没有限制。没有类似“这是你最后可以拥有的州”的限制。所以这有点，你知道的，从某种意义上说，它就像一部扩张主义的宪法，对吧？就像它可以变得随你想要的那样大。这很有趣，因为它也某种程度上与我们对自身的看法相悖，即我们并非特别具有扩张主义，或者至少不是殖民主义者，或者我们如何看待自己，尽管这从未真正成为美国真正运作的一部分。但它是，但我认为这超级有趣。
There's no limit on it. There's no like, and this is the last state you can have. So it's kind of, you know, in a way, it's like an expansionist constitution, right? Like, it can get as big as you want. That is interesting because it's also that's somewhat antithetical to our notion of ourselves is that we weren't especially expansionist or at least a lot colonialists, or how we viewed ourselves, even though it was never really part of the true functioning of the United States. But it was, but I think that's super interesting.
是的。我的意思是，我不知道未来几年事情会如何发展，但我们会拭目以待。休息过后，我们将更多地讨论第四条以及我们对第十修正案的讨论。最后，第四条的最后一部分包含所谓的保障条款。你想读一下保障条款吗？当然。合众国应当保障本联邦的每一个州享有共和政体，
Yeah. I mean, I wonder how things will go in the next couple of years or so, but we'll see. More on Article 4 and our discussion of the 10th Amendment after the break. Finally, the last section of Article 4 contains what's called the guarantee clause. Do you want to read the guarantee clause? Sure. The United States shall guarantee to every state in this union a Republican form of government
并应保护他们中的每一个免受入侵，并且应州议会（或在议会无法召集时应行政长官）的请求，保护他们免受国内暴乱。好的。那么，联邦政府应当保障每个州都拥有共和政体，这究竟意味着什么？这有点难以说明，因为几乎没有任何关于它的判例法。部分原因在于，通常法院已经表示，根据所谓的“政治问题学说”，保障条款不是法院应介入的事情。就像这实际上是一个政治问题，联邦政府的政治分支应该介入其中。但据推测，它存在的原因是为了表明，美国不应接纳拥有极权或专制政府的新州，对吧？没错。所以，我的意思是，我认为这相当清楚。就像我们，联邦政府根据该条款有义务防止任何州，比如说，变成君主国或独裁政权。你知道的，这是一种确保不会发生这种情况的义务。而且总的来说，我认为我们都可以同意，共和政体意味着人民通过
and shall protect each of them against invasion and on application of the legislature or of the executive when the legislature cannot be convened against domestic violence. All right. So what does it mean that the federal government is supposed to guarantee that every state has a Republican form of government? That is kind of hard to say because there's really hardly any case law on it. Part of the reason why is because generally the courts have said the guarantee clause isn't something for courts to get involved in based on what's called the political question doctrine. Like this is really a political issue that the political branches of federal government should get involved in. But presumably what is there for is to say the United States shouldn't admit new states that have totalitarian or authoritative governments, right? Right. So, I mean, I think that's pretty clear. Like we, that the federal government has an obligation under this clause to prevent any state from, you know, becoming a monarchy, let's say, or a dictatorship. You know, it's an obligation to make sure that doesn't happen. And generally speaking, I think we can all agree that a Republican form of government means that the people governed through.
他们的民选官员来进行治理。但这是一个相当宽泛的声明。所以我认为不清楚的是（也许我们永远不会有一个真正确定的答案）：是否存在宪法要求的特定形式的共和政体？例如，一个州在限制谁有权在州内投票方面可以走多远？
through their elected officials. But that's a pretty broad statement. So I think what's not clear, and maybe we'll never have a really definitive answer on, is, like, is there a specific form of Republican government that is constitutionally required? So, for instance, like, how far could a state go and restricting who's allowed to vote within the state?
在某个时候，那是否就不再是一个共和政体了？因为毕竟，如果我们回顾建国时期，建国者们完全乐于将投票权限制在他们自己身上，而不给任何人其他人。所以这有点像一个悬而未决的问题，对吧？所以也许共和政体的保障有点毫无意义，因为它没有为攻击投票权的行径提供强有力的保护。
At some point, would that be no longer a Republican form of government? Because, after all, if we're going to go back to the founding, the founders were perfectly comfortable at restricting the right to vote. to themselves and nobody else. So that's kind of a question left up in the air, right? So maybe the Republican form of government guarantee is a little bit meaningless in the sense that it doesn't provide strong protections against attacks on voting rights.
也许拥有极权主义州政府的威胁非常遥远，也许吧。但是，你知道的，关于什么是共和政体的保障，它是一套相当宽泛的大纲。是的，是的。有趣。然后是第四条的保护条款。联邦政府应保护每个州免受入侵。所以这相当有趣，因为第四条的这一部分要求（那是“应”，对吧？）要求联邦政府保护每个州免受入侵，并在州提出请求时免受国内暴乱。因此，保护条款实际上与宪法的另一部分协同工作，该部分见于
And maybe the threat of having a totalitarian state government is pretty remote, maybe. But, you know, it's a pretty broad set of outlines about what is a guarantee of a Republican form of government. Yeah, yeah. Interesting. And then there is the protection clause of Article 4. The federal government shall protect each of them, the states, against invasion. So this is pretty interesting because this part of Article 4 requires, that's the shall, right? Requires the federal government to protect each state from invasion and from domestic violence if the state asked for it. So the protection clause actually works together with another part of the Constitution, which is found.
第一条，也就是入侵条款。在第一条的入侵条款中，各州实际上不允许在没有真正紧急情况的情况下进行自我防卫，除非它们像宪法所说的那样确实遭到入侵。因此，宪法建立了一种机制，其中联邦政府实际上是负责各州集体安全的机构，对吧？所以这是你真的应该向联邦政府寻求帮助，或者联邦政府应该帮助你（各州）的部分。这不是一个常用的学说，除非你是得克萨斯州。所以I不知你是否还记得在2023年，得克萨斯州认为沿着格兰德河安装一个1000英尺长的浮标系统是个好主意。
in Article 1, that's the invasion clause. In the invasion clause of Article 1, the states are not actually allowed to act in their own defense unless there's like a real emergency, unless they are, as the Constitution says, actually invaded. So the Constitution sets up a scheme where the federal government is actually the one responsible for the collective security of the states, right? So this is the part where you're really supposed to ask the federal government for help or the federal government is supposed to help you the states. Not a commonly used doctrine unless you are Texas. So I don't know if you remember in 2023, Texas thought it would be a good idea to install a 1,000 feet system of buoys along the Rio Grande River.
我发誓你一点也不记得了。嗯，这确实发生了。这是一个巨大的浮标线。它们由重型链条连接，浮标本身大约有四英尺宽，非常大以至于你无法爬过去。本质上，这是为了防止人们通过游过河进入美国，对吧？这主要是象征性的，因为我说过它是一千英尺，对吧？而得克萨斯州与墨西哥的边境大约是1200英里左右。所以它只覆盖了很小的一部分。那为什么得克萨斯州认为它可以这样做呢？
I did you not recall that at all. Well, this happened. This was a giant buoy line. They were connected by heavy chains. and the buoys themselves were like four feet across, so so large that you couldn't kind of climb over them. And essentially, this is to prevent people from crossing into the United States, right, by swimming across the river. It's mostly symbolic because I said it was a thousand feet, right? And the Texas-Mexico border is like 1,200 miles or something like that. So it was only covering a small portion. So why did Texas think it could do this?
嗯，阿博特州长部分依据的是第四条的保护条款，即联邦政府有责任保护该州免受入侵，而联邦政府没有履行其义务。这是在拜登政府时期。当然，阿博特论点有一个巨大的问题。得克萨斯州实际上并没有遭到任何人的入侵。所以就在得克萨斯州部署了这道浮动浮标屏障后不久，联邦政府实际上在联邦法院起诉了得克萨斯州。但实际发生的情况是，拜登政府实际上并没有参与宪法论辩。相反，他们表示得克萨斯州违反了关于河流控制、通航水域的联邦法律，而且此案仍在进行中。
Well, Governor Abbott relied in part on Article 4's protection clause that the federal government had a responsibility to protect the state from invasion, and the federal government wasn't fulfilling its obligations. This is during the Biden administration. Of course, there's a huge problem with Abbott's argument. Texas isn't actually being invaded by anybody. So as soon as Texas implemented this barrier of floating buoys, the federal government actually sued. Texas and federal court over this. But what happened actually is that the Biden administration did not actually engage with the constitutional argument. And instead, they said that Texas was violating federal law about river control, navigable waters, and the case is still ongoing.
我想你大概可以想象为什么他们不想参与宪法论辩。是的。是的。我的意思是，他们绝对不希望最高法院以任何方式对此给出答案。你知道的，法院多数派可能会说这样的话的可能性，即，嗯，实际上，也许得克萨斯州可以进行自我防卫。因为，你知道，你真的想生活在这样一个世界里吗：每个州都可以决定自己遭到入侵，并参与某种自卫行为？对。是的，是的。我希望我们有一些关于入侵的定义，因为它被使用得太多了，而且在政治争论中也被频繁援引。我认为这是非常知情地被援引的，因为它经常被用作导致某种入侵的紧急情况发生的理由。
I think you can kind of imagine why they didn't want to engage with the constitutional argument. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, they did not want this to be answered in any way by the Supreme Court. you know, the possibility that a majority on the court might say something like, well, actually, maybe Texas can defend itself. Because, you know, do you really want to live in a world where each state gets to decide that they're invaded and engage in some kind of self-defense acts? Right. Yeah. Yeah. I wish we had some definitions of invasion because it's used so much and it's also invoked so much in political arguments. I think quite knowingly because it's invoked a lot as the thing that causes an emergency to happen. in an invasion of some kind.
我想你大概能想象为什么他们不想介入宪法争议。是的。是的。我是说，他们绝对不希望最高法院以任何方式对此作出回答。你知道，最高法院多数派可能会说出这样的话，比如，嗯，实际上，也许得州可以自卫。因为，你知道，你真的想生活在这样一个世界里吗：每个州都可以决定自己受到了入侵，并采取某种自卫行为？对的。是的。是的。我希望我们能有一些关于“入侵”的定义，因为它被使用得太多了，而且在政治争论中也被频繁援引。我认为他们是相当刻意地这样做的，因为它经常被援引为引发某种紧急状态的导火索。
It causes something to change. Yeah, it's sort of a free-floating metaphor for, you know, terrorizing people. And then there is Trump 2.0, right? And it turns out that President Trump has used a kind of novel reading of Article 4. On January 20th of 2025, President Trump issued a proclamation called Guaranteeing the state's protection against invasion. And in that proclamation, Trump declared the suspension of, of what the proclamation calls aliens engaged in the invasion across the southern border.
这会导致某些事情发生改变。是的，这有点像一个自由浮动的隐喻，你知道的，用来恐吓人们。然后是特朗普2.0，对吧？事实证明，特朗普总统对第四条进行了一种新颖的解读。在2025年1月20日，特朗普总统发布了一项名为《保证各州免受入侵保护》的公告。在该公告中，特朗普宣布暂停公告所称的在南部边境参与入侵的外国人。
What's the rationale here? Well, part of it is that Trump declared that the federal government had to take steps to fulfill its obligations under Article 4's protection clause. So you can see how a lot of this is getting politicized in ways that I think is, you know, it's going to be hard to imagine how we'd have legal answers to this. Because, again, so much of this seems to be a political determination. if this is really warlike in some way, although even though it doesn't seem like it,
这里的逻辑是什么？嗯，部分原因在于特朗普宣布联邦政府必须采取措施履行其在第四条保护条款下的义务。所以你可以看到，其中很多内容都被政治化了，我认为，你知道的，这将很难想象我们如何能找到法律答案。因为，再说一次，这里面很大一部分似乎是一个政治决定。如果这在某种程度上真的像是一场战争，尽管看起来并不像，
you know, it's a sort of determination that courts are reluctant to say, this is correct, this is a correct determination of invasion, right? And at least in the legitimate foreign policy arena, courts tend not to second guess what the President of the United States does. So it would really be up to a court to kind of step in and say, we're going to do something totally different and decide, no, this is not an invasion.
你知道的，这是一种法院很不愿表态的决定，即这是否正确，这是否是对入侵的正确判定，对吧？至少在合法的外交政策领域，法院往往不会去事后诸葛亮般地去质疑美国总统的行为。因此，真的得由法院来介入，并表示我们要采取完全不同的做法，裁定这并非一次入侵。
Oh, wow. Okay, I can see why people want to avoid to have this. fight, even people who disagree with any of those protections. Yeah, that's why that case still pending over the buoys is a more dry, navigable rivers argument. Yeah, yeah. I would not want to leave this decision up to the Supreme Court at all. Right.
哦，哇。好吧，我能理解为什么人们想要避免这场争端，甚至包括那些不同意其中任何一种保护措施的人。是的，这就是为什么那个关于浮标的案件至今未决的原因，那是一个更枯燥、关于可航行河流的论点。是的，是的。我一点也不想把这个决定交给最高法院。对的。
And so that's Article 4. And I thought today we'd also connect this to another aspect of the Constitution, and that's the 10th Amendment, right? Because the 10th Amendment today is a very important limitation on the federal. government and what it can do to the states. So here's what it says. 10th Amendment. The powers not delegated to the United States by the Constitution nor prohibited by it to the states are reserved to the states, respectively, or to the people. Right. Sounds like it just describes something about the states. You know, I think any smart
这就是第四条。我想今天我们也可以把这与宪法的另一个方面联系起来，那就是第十修正案，对吧？因为今天的第十修正案对联邦政府及其对各州能做的事情构成了非常重要的限制。以下是它的内容。第十修正案。宪法未授予美国或未禁止各州行使的权力，分别由各州保留，或由人民保留。对的。听起来它只是描述了关于各州的一些事情。你知道的，我认为任何聪明的
high school student would say, well, that doesn't do anything, right? But the Supreme Court has actually interpreted the 10th Amendment to impose a limit on the federal government. And the Supreme Court has changed its interpretation of the 10th Amendment over time. But since the 1990s, it's very clear that the states can rely on the 10th Amendment to argue that the federal government has violated a state's rights of sovereignty. So here the Supreme Court isn't actually relying on the text of the 10th Amendment because it really couldn't, right? But more that the 10th Amendment embodies a particular idea of federalism and that the Supreme Court interprets that idea as a limit on federal power.
高中生都会说，嗯，这什么也没做，对吧？但最高法院实际上将第十修正案解释为对联邦政府施加了限制。而且最高法院随着时间推移改变了对第十修正案的解释。但自20世纪90年代以来，非常明显的是，各州可以依靠第十修正案来辩称联邦政府侵犯了各州的主权权利。在这里，最高法院实际上并没有依赖第十修正案的文本，因为它的确无法做到这一点，对吧？而是更多地因为第十修正案体现了一种特定的联邦制理念，最高法院将这种理念解释为对联邦权力的限制。
So what is all that mean? Because I find that a little bit confusing. Okay. So the primary way the court has interpreted the Tenth Amendment, again, not because the text says so, but because the Supreme Court says this stands in for a certain idea of federalism is what the court has called the anti-commandeering doctrine. And again, that word is not in the Tenth Amendment, but it's how the Supreme Court has interpreted the 10th Amendment. And so the idea of anti-commodereing is like this. The federal government
所以这一切到底意味着什么？因为我觉得这有点令人困惑。好的。法院解释第十修正案的主要方式——再次说明，并非因为文本这么写，而是因为最高法院认为这代表了某种联邦制的理念——就是法院所称的反强征原则。同样的，这个词并不在第十修正案中，但这是最高法院对第十修正案的解释。所以反强征的理念是这样的。联邦政府
can't commandeer or order. That's what commandeering means. The states to enact a federal regulatory program and it can't force state officials to enforce federal laws. Right. So the idea is the federal government can't tell the states, look, we have these things we want to do and we want you to pass laws or regulations the way we want you to. Nor can the federal government tell state and local officials, let's say we don't have the resources for our own officials to enforce federal law. You have to do it. So since the 1990s, the Supreme Court's made it absolutely clear that this kind of action
不能强征或命令——这就是强征的意思——各州去颁布一项联邦监管计划，它也不能强迫州官员去执行联邦法律。对的。所以这个理念是，联邦政府不能对各州说，看，我们有这些想做的事情，我们希望你们按照我们的意愿通过法律或法规。联邦政府也不能对州和地方官员说，比方说我们自己的官员没有资源来执行联邦法律，你们必须去做。所以自20世纪90年代以来，最高法院已经非常明确地指出，这种行为
is unconstitutional. Why? Because this would upset the balance of power that the Supreme Court sees between the federal government and the governments of the states. And they see that embodied in the 10th Amendment. Really, the 10th time is kind of like standing in for this idea. Yeah, yeah. So that's pretty clear.
是违宪的。为什么？因为这会打破最高法院所看到的联邦政府与州政府之间的权力平衡。他们认为这体现在第十修正案中。实际上，第十修正案有点像是代表了这种理念。是的，是的。所以这很清楚。
So really what it's telling Congress is there are certain things you can do, like you can regulate, you know, commerce moving across state lines. You can tell persons, private entities to do things, right, to behave in certain ways. But you can't tell the states to do things in ways that are treating them like they're your servants, essentially, right? That's what the anti-commenteering clause means. And this idea has also been extended to the spending power too. The federal government can certainly offer financial incentives to the states under Congress's spending power, which we find in Article 1, on the condition that the states do what the federal government wants.
所以它真正告诉国会的是，有些事情你是可以做的，比如你可以监管跨州边界流动的商业。你可以指示个人、私人实体去做某些事情，对吧，以某种特定方式行事。但你不能以对待仆人般的方式指使各州做事，对吧？这就是反强征条款的含义。这一理念也被扩大到了支出权力上。在国会的支出权力下，联邦政府当然可以向各州提供财政激励——我们可以在第一条中找到这一点——条件是各州必须按联邦政府的要求行事。
Now, it might seem Roman like this is kind of similar to commandeering, right? Like, well, I can't, you know, we want you to do something. Here's some money. But the idea under federal spending authority is theoretically states have a choice. They can say no. Yeah, they can say no. We don't want to do this. We don't feel like listening to federal government.
现在，罗曼，这看起来可能有点类似于强征，对吧？就像，好吧，我不能，你知道，我们想让你做点什么，给你点钱。但在联邦支出权力之下的理念是，从理论上讲，各州是有选择权的。它们可以说不。是的，它们可以说不。我们不想这么做。我们不想听联邦政府的话。
And because they have a choice, it doesn't raise the same problem. Except in some cases, the Supreme Court has said that if the choice is not a true choice, in other words, it's really deemed coercive, that the spending power also can go too far in a way that is similar to the anti-commandering principle. Because you really are forcing the states in a way that they don't want to behave. And that's essentially why in 2012 the Supreme Court's decision upholding Obamacare, the Affordable Care Act, that was the reason that one portion of it was one in which the Supreme Court struck down the way that the ACA expanded Medicaid, right? Because it was offering the state's money to expand Medicaid. But if they didn't decide to expand it, they would lose all of their current funding as well. And the court said, that's not a true choice. You're really forcing them to do things that they don't want to do.
正因为它们有选择权，所以不会引发同样的问题。但在某些情况下，最高法院表示，如果这种选择不是真正的选择，换句话说，它实际上被认为具有胁迫性，那么支出权力也可能走得太远，其方式类似于反强征原则。因为你确实是在以一种它们不愿意的方式强迫各州行事。这基本上就是为什么在2012年最高法院支持奥巴马医改（即《平价医疗法案》）的判决中，那一部分被最高法院推翻的原因，即ACA扩大医疗救助（Medicaid）的方式，对吧？因为它是通过向各州提供资金来扩大医疗救助的。但如果它们决定不扩大，它们也将失去所有的现有资金。法院表示，这不是真正的选择。你确实在强迫它们做它们不想做的事。
Okay. And that's why when that decision came out in the very beginning, when people read it quickly the first time, they thought that the ACA had been struck down. But it turned out that it was another part of it where it cuts fighted it as a tax and therefore did have the power to it that upheld it. Yeah. And then that's why the ACA has been alive ever since. The one portion of it was struck down, but the vast majority of the ACA stood. And this is where we get the phrase in one of the opinions that you can't have a gun to the head.
好的。这就是为什么当那个判决刚出来时，人们第一次快速阅读时，以为ACA已经被推翻了。但事实证明，是它的另一部分——将其定性为一种税收，因此确实拥有这样做的权力——维持了它。是的。这就是为什么ACA自那以后一直存活了下来。其中一部分被推翻了，但绝大多数ACA条款都保留了下来。这就是我们在其中一份意见书中看到这句名言的由来：你不能拿枪指着别人的头。
That's the thing. The Supreme Court chooses this pretty violent metaphor of saying, you know, giving or offering money on the condition of is kind of like putting the gun to the head of the states, which is, number one, weird because, you know, it's treating states as if they're people and that they have some independent authority or, like, control. It's actually our representatives. We've made choices. A lot of states didn't mind the Medicaid expansion. You know, but that's, in a way, what you point out to is funny because the Supreme Court has said that the anti-commandering principle, right, which is that the federal government can't treat the states in particular ways, that applies even if the states say, let's say the states want to participate in a regulatory program and they say, sure, regulate us this way. And the federal government does it. The Supreme Court has made it very clear.
就是这样。最高法院选择了这种相当暴力的隐喻，说，你知道，以某种条件给予或提供资金，有点像是把枪抵在各州的头上。这首先很奇怪，因为，你知道，它把各州当作人来看待，认为它们具有某种独立的权威或控制力。这实际上是我们的代表。我们做出了选择。许多州并不介意扩大医疗救助。你知道，但在某种程度上，你所指出的这一点很有趣，因为最高法院已经表示，反强征原则——也就是联邦政府不能以特定方式对待各州——甚至在各州表示愿意的情况下也适用，比方说各州想要参与一项监管计划，并且说，当然，请以这种方式监管我们。而联邦政府也这么做了。最高法院已经说得非常清楚了。
The states can't even consent to it. The states can't even get together and say, oh, please commandeer us. the court says federalism is so important it doesn't matter if nobody wants it that we are here to uphold it. So it's not that some goals are good and some are bad. It's simply telling Congress you cannot do it in this way. Yeah. Yeah. I admire that sort of ideological consistency, honestly.
各州甚至都不能对此表示同意。各州甚至不能聚在一起说，哦，请强征我们吧。法院表示，联邦制是如此重要，以至于没有人想要它也无关紧要，我们在这里就是为了维护它。所以这并不是说有些目标是好的，有些是坏的。它只是在告诉国会，你不能以这种方式行事。是的。说实话，我很赞赏这种意识形态上的一致性。
Sure. I mean, it's just like a little bit. I mean, like amongst all this sort of like floating on the sea of all this argument and stuff, like, and it seems like things just break. politically, it's kind of nice to know that even if everyone is agreeing to the coercion and the commandeering, that they're just like, no, this is not how we do things. We do things differently. I'm kind of down with that. Okay. Well, for sure, then you're agreeing with the majority, which, you know, the court has said repeatedly. It doesn't happen a lot, but every once in a while. Yeah. And in a way, it does make sense to have that consistency because we see the 10th Amendment's
当然。我的意思是，这只是一点点。我的意思是，在所有这些漂浮在各种争论之海中的事物之间，当事情似乎在政治上破裂时，知道即使每个人都同意胁迫和强征，他们仍然会说，不，这不是我们做事的方式，我们有不同的做事方式，这种感觉其实挺好的。我挺赞成这一点的。好吧，当然，那么你是同意多数派的观点了，你知道的，法院已经多次说过这一点。这种情况虽然不常见，但偶尔会发生。是的。从某种程度上说，保持这种一致性确实是有道理的，因为我们看到了第十修正案的
anti-commodering principle. It's not. a blue state weapon nor a red state weapon. It is an argument that states make against the federal government, right? Yeah, yeah. So there's another less commonly discussed aspect of the 10th Amendment, and it's called the equal sovereignty doctrine. Again, it's not in there. Doesn't refer to it. Yeah, clearly. None of those words are there. None of those words are there. But the court has recognized this idea and the idea of equal sovereignty is that Congress can't pass laws that treat states unequally or at least probably they can't do so unless they have a really, really, really good reason, right?
反强征原则。它既不是蓝州的武器，也不是红州的武器。这是各州用来对抗联邦政府的论据，对吧？是的，是的。所以第十修正案还有一个较少被讨论的方面，被称为平等主权原则。同样，它并不在其中。文中没有提及。是的，显然没有。这些词一个也没有。这些词一个也没有。但法院已经承认了这种理念，平等主权原则的理念是，国会不能通过不平等对待各州的法律，或者至少可能它们不能这样做，除非它们有非常、非常、非常充分的理由，对吧？
So it's one of those good reasons. Yeah. So in Shelby County versus Holder in 2013, the Supreme Court struck down parts of the Voting Rights Act and part of what was disputed were certain identifications. Like if you're a jurisdiction with a history of racial discrimination, you had a sense. certain formula that applied to you. And that formula meant that these jurisdictions had to obtain what the law called preclearance from the Justice Department before changing any voting procedures. And part of the reason the Supreme Court struck down these provisions of the VRA, they said that was a departure from the fundamental principle of equal sovereignty. So that's a big voting rights case,
所以这是那些充分理由之一。是的。因此，在2013年的“谢尔比县诉霍尔德案”（Shelby County v. Holder）中，最高法院推翻了《选举权法案》（Voting Rights Act）的部分内容，其中引发争议的部分涉及某些身份认定。例如，如果你是一个有种族歧视历史的司法管辖区，你就要遵循某种特定的标准。这个标准意味着这些司法管辖区在改变任何投票程序之前，必须获得法律所称的来自司法部的“事前批准”（preclearance）。最高法院推翻《选举权法案》这些条款的部分原因在于，他们认为这是对平等主权这一基本原则的背离。所以这当然是一个重大的选举权案件，
of course. But it's sort of unclear what that would mean outside of the voting rights context. But I think in Trump's second term, I would expect with more and more threats against some states than not others, you'll see some states with Democratic governors invoking this idea that we are being punished because we're not going along with Trump's agenda. So it will certainly be used the 10th Amendment generally and perhaps the equal sovereignty doctrine in particular as some kind of constitutional shield as Trump tries to force the states to do his bidding. the second time. Yeah, yeah. And in the past, this has been used because the states were bad actors in this case, like, or these counties were doing racist things to stop people from voting. And therefore, the long history of that has made it so that you have to check with us if you change anything. But that's not the case when it, you know, when it comes to however people think these states are misbehaving today when it comes to immigration. Yeah. And so it really, you know, it just shows you how much like all of these doctrines in. one era look like a bad idea can sometimes be a good idea. A lot of this is contextual. It definitely makes the process of governance really messy, right? I mean, when states get to object in all of these different ways, you know, if we want a sort of national system where you have uniform laws,
当然。但目前尚不清楚这在选举权语境之外意味着什么。但我认为在特朗普的第二个总统任期内，我预计随着针对某些州而非其他州的威胁越来越多，你会看到一些由民主党州长的州开始援引这种观点，即我们正在受到惩罚，因为我们不愿顺从特朗普的议程。因此，第十修正案总体上，以及尤其是平等主权原则，肯定会被用作某种宪法盾牌，因为特朗普第二次试图强迫各州按照他的意愿行事。是的，是的。在过去，这种原则被使用是因为各州在这个案例中是不良行为者，比如这些县在采取种族主义行为来阻止人们投票。因此，由于其悠久的历史，使得你必须在改变任何东西之前先与我们核对。但当涉及到今天人们认为这些州在移民问题上行为不端时，情况就并非如此了。是的。所以这确实，你知道，它向你展示了在不同的时代，所有这些看起来像是坏主意的信条有时如何能变成好主意。很多事情都是有语境的。这绝对会让治理的过程变得非常混乱，对吧？我的意思是，当各州以所有这些不同的方式提出反对意见时，你知道，如果我们想要一个拥有统一法律的全国性系统，
in some ways the court's response to this, because they've interpreted the 10th Amendment in all these different ways, they're saying, you know, efficiency is not the goal here. The goal is to make sure that the different parts have their kind of respect that the Constitution accords them. Okay. Yeah, I find myself feeling more or less into states' rights depending on the subject. To tell you the truth. That's fair. Yeah.
在某种程度上，法院对此的回应是——因为它们以各种不同的方式解释了第十修正案——它们在说，你知道，效率并不是这里的目标。目标是确保不同的部分能够得到宪法赋予它们的某种尊重。好的。是的，说实话，根据主题的不同，我发现自己对各州权利的支持时多时少。这很公平。是的。
We've definitely seen those fault lines already. So that's all of Article 4 and a little bit of a 10th Amendment, which relates to it. Cool. This is awesome. Thank you so much. Thanks, Herman. When we come back, California Attorney General Rob Bonta talks about the powers granted to the states under the Constitution and how California is using the courts to push back against the Trump administration. And now our conversation with California Attorney General Rob Bonta.
我们确实已经看到了这些断层线。这就是第四条的全部内容，以及与它相关的第十修正案的一小部分。太棒了。这太棒了。非常感谢。谢谢你，赫尔曼。当我们回来时，加州总检察长罗布·邦塔将谈论宪法赋予各州的权力，以及加州如何利用法院来回击特朗普政府。现在是我们与加州总检察长罗布·邦塔的对话。
Since Trump took office in January of last year, California has sued the administration more than 50 times, about a rate of one lawsuit a week. Courts have found in the state's favor about 80% of the time, although many of those decisions are, are from lower courts. Attorney General Bonta wasn't always so concerned with the federal government. He took over the job in 2021, when then AG J. J. J. J. Havier Bacera left to join the Biden administration. Over those four years, Bonta's office was mostly focused on issues like consumer protection and upholding Biden's environmental regulations. Now his relationship with federal government is decidedly adversarial. We start with how the job has changed for him, before Trump was elected, and after. You know, we were doing the things we're supposed to be doing, being by the side of the people as they face their biggest challenges, tackling issues of public safety, fentanyl, human trafficking, hate crimes, organized retail crime. We were fighting for rights and protections, constitutional rights, civil rights, access to health care, making sure the housing was being built, making sure there was safety from gun violence, making sure we were taking appropriate climate action. And then Mr. Trump was elected president.
自从特朗普去年一月份上台以来，加州已经起诉了政府50多次，大约是一周一起诉讼的频率。法院大约有80%的判决对加州有利，尽管其中许多判决是来自下级法院。总检察长邦塔过去并非总是如此关注联邦政府。他于2021年接任这一职务，当时前总检察长泽维尔·贝塞拉（Xavier Becerra）离职加入拜登政府。在那四年里，邦塔的办公室主要关注消费者保护和维护拜登的环境法规等问题。现在，他与联邦政府的关系显然变成了对抗性的。我们首先从他上任前后工作发生的变化谈起，在特朗普当选之前和之后。你知道的，我们一直在做我们应该做的事情，在人们面临最大挑战时站在他们身边，应对公共安全、芬太尼、人口贩运、仇恨犯罪、有组织零售犯罪等问题。我们在为权利和保护而战，宪法权利、民权、获得医疗保健的途径，确保住房正在建设中，确保免受枪支暴力的安全，确保我们正在采取适当的行动应对气候变化。然后特朗普先生当选为总统。
And all the things we were doing before, we continue to do. And we also are taking on the additional role and work of holding this administration accountable when it breaks the law. We have a simple proposition. If Trump breaks the law, we sue him. If he doesn't break the law, we don't sue him. Our sweet spot is the facts and the law. Courts where we're in sanitized environments free of politics, where we can present. the facts and apply the law. And we have brought 55 lawsuits in less than that many weeks,
我们以前做的事情，现在全部都在继续。我们同时也肩负着新的角色和工作，那就是在该届政府违法时追究其责任。我们的立场很简单：如果特朗普违法，我们就起诉他；如果他没有违法，我们就不会起诉他。我们的核心优势在于事实与法律。法院是一个没有政治干扰的纯净环境，我们可以在那里陈述事实并适用法律。在不到同样周数的时间里，我们已经提起了55起诉讼，
so more than one lawsuit a week. And we've won 80% of the time. We've protected $188 billion worth of funding that Trump unlawfully tried to withhold from California. We protected key rights and freedoms like birthright citizenship, voting rights. We were able to get the unlawfully federalized National Guard out of California after six. months of fighting tooth and nail and, you know, we're fighting on many fronts. So that is a politician's answer, a long answer to a short question. I didn't imagine. I would be doing this, but our life has changed considerably, but we continue to do all the things we were doing before. Plus, on top of that, we've added the important work of holding a president accountable when he
也就是说平均每周不止一起诉讼。而且我们的胜诉率高达80%。我们成功保护了特朗普企图非法扣留加州的价值1880亿美元的资金。我们保护了出生公民权、投票权等核心权利与自由。经过长达六个月的全力抗争，我们成功将非法联邦化的国民警卫队撤出了加州，而且你知道，我们在多条战线上都在战斗。所以，这是一个政客式的回答，是对一个简单问题的长篇大论。我以前从未想过自己会做这件事，但我们的生活发生了很大变化，不过我们一直在继续做以前所有的工作。除此之外，我们还增添了一项重要工作，那就是在一个总统
breaks the law. So, you know, Trump's campaign, obviously for his second term, focused on his mass deportation agenda, and we're seeing that in action for the past year in places like Los Angeles and Chicago and, of course, Minneapolis. But I think one of the things that is often confusing is there are many terms in the immigration debate, and the biggest one is probably the idea of a sanctuary jurisdiction. And California is, as a matter of state law, a sanctuary state. So could you explain what being a sanctuary state means in practical terms? Sure. And it's not a term I prefer. I prefer to say a pro. public safety, pro-community trust state.
违法时追究其责任。所以，大家都知道，特朗普第二任期的竞选主要围绕他的大规模驱逐计划展开，我们在过去一年里已经在洛杉矶、芝加哥以及当然还有明尼阿波利斯等地方看到了这一计划的实施。但我想，其中一件容易让人感到困惑的事情是，移民辩论中存在许多术语，其中最大的一个可能就是“庇护司法管辖区”这个概念。而根据州法律，加州就是一个庇护州。那么，您能否从实际层面解释一下，作为一个庇护州究竟意味着什么？当然。这其实并不是我最喜欢的词。我更愿意称之为一个支持公共安全、支持社区信任的州。
Okay. As enshrined in our California Values Act, which you've referred to, passed in 2017, in Jurn Trump 1.0. And it basically says that the limited and vital criminal law enforcement resources of California will focus on crime. They'll focus on tackling crime like murder and rape
好的。正如我们在2017年特朗普第一任期内通过的、您刚才提到的《加州价值观法案》中所阐明的那样，它基本上规定，加州有限且至关重要的刑事执法资源将集中用于打击犯罪。它们将专注于打击谋杀、强奸
and robbery and assault and battery and not be used, with some exceptions, to engage in civil immigration enforcement, particularly when there is a whole set of federal departments and agencies that enforce immigration laws, ICE, the Department of Homeland Security, among them. And so that is fully within our 10th Amendment rights to take that position, to want to focus on crime,
以及抢劫、攻击和殴打等犯罪活动，除了一些例外情况外，这些资源将不用于参与民事移民执法，特别是当有一整套联邦部门和机构（其中包括移民及海关执法局、国土安全部）专门负责执行移民法律的时候。因此，采取这种立场、希望专注于打击犯罪，完全在我们第十修正案所赋予的权利范围内，
to take the position that when victims feel safe and able to come forward, when witnesses can come forward and report, crime to law enforcement, then crimes will get solved in communities are safer. And certainly the federal government can enforce federal immigration law if they do that lawfully. And the states cannot obstruct or interfere. But the anti-commandeering principle of the 10th Amendment, which provides strong rights for states. And the 10th Amendment basically says that all powers that are not delegated to the United States government or prohibited from the states from having are provided
并且秉持这样一种立场：当受害者感到安全并愿意站出来，当目击者能够站出来向执法部门举报犯罪时，社区中的罪案就能得到侦破，社区也会变得更加安全。当然，如果联邦政府合法地执行联邦移民法，他们完全可以这样做，而各州不得阻挠或干涉。但是，第十修正案的“反强制征用”原则为各州提供了强有力的权利。第十修正案基本上规定，所有未授予美国政府或未禁止各州拥有的权力，都保留给
to the states or the people. And that is where this anti-commandering principle exists, where it says that the federal government can enforce federal law, but they can't force states to do their job for them. They can't commandeer them, conscript them, draft them into service, force them to do the federal government's job for it. So that is a sense. essentially what is meant by sanctuary or jurisdiction or, you know, my words, pro public safety, pro community trust. But the word sanctuary, unfortunately, has taken on a very different meaning in the world. Some people very, very wrongly think it means it's a safe haven for criminals. Absolutely not true. Our position in California has been, we will focus on crime.
各州或人民。正是基于这一“反强制征用”原则，联邦政府可以执行联邦法律，但他们不能强迫各州替他们干活。他们不能将各州强征、强募、征召入伍，强迫各州去完成联邦政府的工作。所以，这就是“庇护司法管辖区”或者用我自己的话说“支持公共安全、支持社区信任”的实质含义。但在世界上，“庇护”这个词不幸被赋予了非常不同的含义。有些人非常错误地认为这意味着这里是犯罪分子的避难场所。事实绝对并非如此。我们在加州的一贯立场是：我们将专注于打击犯罪。
And we won't have our critical resources diverted for civil immigration enforcement. and we will investigate crime, arrest for crime, prosecute for crime, regardless of your immigration status. So a lot gets lost in translation, unfortunately, but that's what it means to be a quote-unquote sanctuary jurisdiction or a pro-public safety, pro-community trust jurisdiction. So practically speaking, that sounds like that means that, you know, of course, federal agents can come in and enforce the federal law, but, you know, your local police agency doesn't have to really lift a finger to aid that if they don't wish to, is that right?
而且我们不会将关键资源挪用到民事移民执法上去；无论您的移民身份如何，我们都会对犯罪进行调查、逮捕和起诉。因此，不幸的是，许多信息在翻译过程中被曲解了，但这就是所谓的“庇护司法管辖区”或“支持公共安全、支持社区信任的司法管辖区”的真正含义。所以从实际角度来看，这听起来就像是说，联邦特工当然可以进来执行联邦法律，但你们当地的警察机构如果不想帮忙，根本不需要动一根手指，对吗？
Right. And they're actually in most cases prohibited from participating in civil immigration enforcement. You know, tackling crime, another story. We're in joint task forces all over the place when it comes to tackling fentanyl and human trafficking and organized retail crime and gun violence, gun trafficking, folks involved in murders. We're working with the federal government all the time. But when it comes to civil immigration enforcement, SB 54 prohibits that, with some exceptions for serious. and violent crimes and detainers where there's a request from ICE to pick up someone who's being released from a jail or a police department and they have a qualifying serious or violent crime. They can, under those limited circumstances, there can be cooperation with the federal government. Yeah, so let me go back for a moment. You know, this idea, the 10th Amendment means, as the Supreme Court's interpreted, that, you know,
没错。而且在大多数情况下，他们实际上是被禁止参与民事移民执法工作的。至于打击犯罪，那是另一回事。在打击芬太尼、人口贩运、有组织零售犯罪、枪支暴力、枪支走私以及涉谋杀人员方面，我们随处都参与了联合工作组。我们一直在与联邦政府合作。但当涉及到民事移民执法时，第54号参议院法案（SB 54）禁止这样做，不过对于严重和暴力犯罪以及由移民及海关执法局发出、要求接走某个正从监狱或警察部门释放且犯有符合条件的严重或暴力犯罪人员的拘留请求，则存在一些例外情况。在这些有限的情况下，是可以与联邦政府进行合作的。是的，让我退回一步说。第十修正案的意思，正如最高法院所解释的那样，意味着
the federal government can't, you've said the word conscript and force the states to do the federal government's bidding. And so there's a pretty clear line in the constitutional sand about what states aren't supposed to be told what to do, right? But I think the question that folks have is, well, on the one hand, you know, you've said that states don't have to help an immigration enforcement, but the Justice Department has also said that, you know, look, if state or local officials interfere with federal immigration enforcement, they could be charged with obstruction. So where do you see that line between states legally declining to help, but also, in the state's and maybe not interfering with immigration enforcement?
联邦政府不能——正如你刚才用过的词——强征并迫使各州听命于联邦政府。因此，在宪法层面上，关于哪些方面不应强求各州做什么，有一条相当清晰的红线，对吧？但我认为大家可能会问的问题是：一方面，正如你所说，各州不必协助移民执法，但司法部也曾表示，如果州或地方官员干涉联邦移民执法，他们可能会被控妨碍司法公正。那么，你认为在“各州合法拒绝协助”与“同时不干涉移民执法”之间，这条界限在哪里？
Legally declining to help legally and constitutionally, declining to focus critical state resources on public safety, on crime, is nowhere near the line. And so being a quote-unquote sanctuary jurisdiction is nowhere near the line of obstruction or interference. I know that the federal government likes to be very aggressive and its interpretation of what constitutes obstruction and interference, they seek to suggest or even explicitly say that just being a quote-unquote sanctuary jurisdiction somehow crosses that line into obstruction and interference,
从法律和宪法层面合法拒绝协助，拒绝将关键的州资源集中用于公共安全和打击犯罪，这与那条红线相去甚远。因此，成为所谓的“庇护司法管辖区”，与妨碍或干涉司法公正的红线毫无关系。我知道联邦政府在对什么是妨碍和干涉的解释上表现得非常激进，他们试图暗示甚至明确宣称，仅仅成为所谓的“庇护司法管辖区”就会在某种程度上越过红线，构成妨碍和干涉，
and they're just dead wrong on it. Like there are many things, like when Trump said that, you know, he wasn't sure if the due process clause of the United States Constitution applied to people as opposed to citizens. He didn't know. And, you know, he had a contempt for the law. He recently said that the federal government, Well, he said the Republicans should nationalize elections, where the Elections Clause in the United States Constitution says that elections are predominantly a area for states to determine the time, place, and manner of those elections.
但他们的这种看法大错特错。就像很多事情一样，比如当特朗普说他不知道美国宪法的正当程序条款是适用于个人还是仅仅适用于公民时。他不知道。而且，你知道的，他一直对法律抱有一种蔑视态度。他最近甚至说，联邦政府——哦，他说的是共和党人应该将选举收归国营，而美国宪法中的选举条款却明确规定，选举在很大程度上属于各州确立选举时间、地点和方式的权限范围。
So they do try to use the law as a cudgel with very robust, expansive, incorrect interpretations. But being a sanctuary jurisdiction, a quote unquote sanctuary jurisdiction is nowhere near the line. And don't just take my word from it for the ninth circuit. it already decided this issue. You know, it's done and dusted, decided already back in Trump 1.0 when the Ninth Circuit said that SB 54 is upheld and fully within California's 10th Amendment constitutional rights. You know, something like physically obstructing, you know, assaulting a immigration officer in the lawful execution of official duties of immigration enforcement, you know, that's something that crosses the line. That's what obstruction is.
因此，他们确实试图用生硬、夸大且不正确的法律解释把法律当作大棒来挥舞。但作为一个庇护司法管辖区，所谓的庇护司法管辖区，与那条红线相去甚远。而且不要只听我一面之词，第九巡回上诉法院已经对这个问题做出了裁决。你知道的，这已经是尘埃落定、早有定论的事了，早在特朗普第一任期内，第九巡回上诉法院就裁定SB 54法案合宪，并且完全在加州第十修正案赋予的宪法权利之内。当然，像是对移民执法官员在依法执行公务时进行物理阻挠、袭击，那种行为才真正越过了红线。那才是妨碍，
interference is, but not a state executing its constitutional rights under the 10th Amendment to be a pro-public safety, pro-public community trust jurisdiction. Right. And what about the reverse scenario? You know, after ICE agents fatally shot Renee Good and Alex Pruddy in Minneapolis, you know, Minnesota officials said that the federal government was actually preventing them from conducting their own state and local criminal investigations doing basic things like preserving evidence. So, how should we understand that kind of state and federal conflict? And, you know, how is the state of California preparing for that potential scenario? I'll first say that we are in some unprecedented,
那才是干涉，而绝不是指一个州在行使其根据第十修正案享有的宪法权利，来做一个支持公共安全、支持社区信任的司法管辖区。没错。那如果是相反的情况呢？你知道的，在移民局特工在明尼阿波利斯开枪打死雷妮·古德（Renee Good）和亚历克斯·普鲁迪（Alex Pruddy）之后，明尼苏达州的官员表示，联邦政府实际上一直在阻止他们进行自己独立的州和地方刑事调查，阻止他们做诸如保护证据之类的基础工作。那么，我们应该如何理解这种州与联邦之间的冲突？以及，加州又该如何为这种潜在的情况做好准备？首先我想说的是，我们正处于前所未有、
uncharted territory. Unfortunately, there has long been a spirit of cooperation between the federal government and state and local governments when it comes to, for example, a crime that occurs in a state and there could be concurrent overlapping jurisdiction. There's been sharing of the evidence. sharing of access to the crime scene, the ability for each jurisdiction to fulfill their roles. But the federal government has changed in its position and shown a unwillingness to cooperate. After the murder, excuse me, the killing and maybe murder, TBD of Renee Good, the federal government immediately said it would not investigate. And the tradition has been for the United States Department of Justice Civil Rights Division,
未曾涉足的领域。不幸的是，长期以来，当例如在某州发生了一起可能存在竞合管辖权（concurrent overlapping jurisdiction）的犯罪时，联邦政府与州及地方政府之间一直保持着一种合作精神。过去一直存在证据共享、犯罪现场通行权限共享，以及各方履行各自职责的能力。但联邦政府的立场已经发生了变化，并表现出不愿意合作的意愿。在雷妮·古德被害——对不起，是丧生，或许可以说是谋杀，结论还有待确定——之后，联邦政府立即表示不会进行调查。而此前的传统一直是，美国司法部民事权利司
to investigate, at least look, gather the facts, pull them together. Maybe you conclude that there's no reason to take any additional steps, but you won't even look. You don't even care about the facts. You're just going to decide. It seems so purely political. And I think the whole country saw that. And then keeping evidence and access to the crime scene from local prosecutors, from state prosecutors, it was unprecedented and inappropriate. We recently issued some guidance here in California in the wake of these positions being taken by the federal government, these unprecedented positions, these very problematic positions, these positions that are contrary to law. And we had seen statements made by people like the vice president, J.D. Vance, saying that federal immigration officials enjoy absolute immunity. and people like United States Deputy Attorney General Todd Blant saying to us in a letter to me and the governor that to attempt to investigate or prosecute federal officials, including immigration enforcement officials for committing crime in California is, you know, his words, illegal and futile. And that's just not true. If a federal agent, including a federal immigration enforcement agent, commits a crime on California.
会展开调查，至少会进行审视、收集事实并将它们拼凑起来。也许最终你的结论是没有理由采取任何额外步骤，但你甚至连看都不看一眼。你甚至根本不在乎事实。你只会直接做出决定。这看起来是如此的纯粹政治化。我想全国人民都看在眼里。然后，把证据和犯罪现场的准入权限对本地检察官、州检察官进行封锁，这是前所未有且极不恰当的。我们最近在加州发布了一些指导意见，正是为了应对联邦政府采取的这些立场，这些前所未有的立场、这些极具问题性的立场、这些违背法律的立场。我们此前听到副总统J.D.万斯（J.D. Vance）等人发表言论称，联邦移民官员享有绝对豁免权；美国副总检察长托德·布兰特（Todd Blant）等人在给我和州长的信中也对我们说，试图调查或起诉联邦官员（包括移民执法官员）在加州犯罪的行为，用他的话说，是“非法的且徒劳的”。这根本不是事实。如果一名联邦特工，包括联邦移民执法特工，在加州土地上对加州人
California soil against a Californian, can a California law enforcement entity investigate and prosecute 1,000% yes. So we know what our rights are. We know what the law provides. Our North Star is the law and the facts. That's what we follow. And we know that if we had something like occurred in Minnesota happening in California, I hope it doesn't. It was terrible. It was tragic. It was disgusting and unacceptable, we know what our rights are. So even in Trump's first term, California and other democratically led states were threatened with the loss of millions of dollars in federal funding if they did not cooperate with immigration enforcement.
实施了犯罪，加州的执法机构是否有权进行调查和起诉？一千个百分之百可以。所以我们清楚自己的权利是什么。我们知道法律规定了什么。我们的北极星就是法律和事实。这就是我们遵循的准则。我们知道，如果在加州发生类似明尼阿波利斯那样的事情——我希望不要发生，那是可怕的、悲惨的、令人作呕且不可接受的——我们很清楚自己的权利。因此，即使在特朗普的第一任期内，加州和其他民主党领导的州也曾受到威胁，如果他们不配合移民执法，数百万美元的联邦资金将被扣发。
And we're seeing these same threats again in Trump's second term. And, you know, it is typical for the federal government to attach conditions to monies that it gives to states. But could you explain why these threats to Yang federal funds particularly violate states' rights and what kind of funding threats has California faced? Yeah. The Trump administration from, as you mentioned, from Trump 1.0 to Trump 2.0 has used a common,
我们在特朗普的第二任期内再次看到了这些相同的威胁。而且，你知道，联邦政府在向各州发放资金时附加条件是很常见的，但您能解释一下，这些威胁扣发联邦资金的行为为什么特别侵犯了各州的权利？以及加州面对过什么样的资金威胁？是的。特朗普政府从——正如你所提到的，从特朗普1.0到特朗普2.0——一直使用一种常见的方法，
I call it a move and approach to try to unlawfully force states, mostly blue states, democratic states, let's be clear about it, to change their policies consistent with what the federal government wants. And they have used coercive, funding approaches, basically threatened to withhold literally billions of dollars worth of funding, funding for transportation, funding to provide cybersecurity or fund of counterterrorism, or to even support victims of crime, that they would pull that funding, that, by the way,
我称之为“故伎重施”的方法，试图非法迫使各州（主要是蓝州、也就是民主党执政的州，我们得把话说清楚）改变其政策，使其符合联邦政府的意愿。他们使用了强迫性的资金手段，基本上威胁要扣留字面意义上高达数十亿美元的资金——用于交通的资金、用于提供网络安全或资助反恐的资金，甚至是为了支持犯罪受害者的资金。他们威胁要撤回这些资金，而这些资金本来是由
the branch of government, the legislative branch, Congress in Article 1 has already appropriated. the power of the purse. And they already said that funding should flow. But over there on the, you know, Article 2 executive branch, the president's saying you're not getting the funding that you've already been appropriated if you don't engage in immigration enforcement the way we want you to. And, you know, trying to change the policies that we have in California and in other states, the so-called sanctuary policies. And there is an ability to encourage or incent certain behavior. the federal government can do that with its funding, but it can't coerce or compel. When pressure turns into compulsion, then it violates the rules of federalism and violates
政府分支机构、即第一条所规定的国会立法机构已经拨款确认的。这就是“钱袋子”权力。他们已经说过这笔资金应该拨付下去。但处于第二条的行政分支、即总统却在说，如果你不按我们想要的方式参与移民执法，你将拿不到已经为你拨款的资金。而且，他们试图改变我们在加州和其他州实行的政策，也就是所谓的庇护政策。当然，政府有能力去鼓励或激励某种特定的行为，联邦政府可以通过其资金支持做到这一点，但它不能进行胁迫或强制。当压力演变成强制时，它就违反了联邦制原则，并且违反了
the 10th Amendment and the spending clause. And there's a set of cases that the U.S. Supreme Court decided where a modest incentive, for example, in South Dakota, there was a federal government that said, you know, you're not going to get 5% of the state federal highway funding that we would normally only give you unless you raise the drinking age to 21 because that'll make the highways more safe. That was allowed. It was 5%. It was probably less than one half of one percent of South Dakota's overall budget. And then later, when there was a policy from the federal government to withhold all of a state's Medicaid funding, if it opted out of the Affordable Care Act's Medicaid expansion, that was found to be
第十修正案以及支出条款（spending clause）。美国最高法院曾审理过一系列案件，其中涉及一种温和的激励措施。例如，在南达科他州，联邦政府曾表示：除非你们将饮酒年龄提高到21岁，因为这会让公路更安全，否则我们将不会发放本应按常规只发给你们的联邦州际公路建设资金的5%。这种做法是被允许的。那只是5%的资金。它可能还不到南达科他州整体预算的百分之零点五。后来，当联邦政府出台了一项政策，即如果一个州选择退出《平价医疗法案》的医疗补助扩容计划，就会被扣发该州所有的医疗补助资金时，该政策被认定为
coercive. It was essentially a gun to the head and it left no real option. But, to do the bidding of the federal government, and that under the Tenth Amendment and the spending clause rules could not occur. So here, we have beat the Trump administration four times in the last year on this move, on the Trump administration, trying to condition funding California is owed
具有强制性。这基本上就是把枪顶在头上，让各州别无选择，
on a requirement that we engage in immigration enforcement the way he wants us to. We beat him when it came to Department of Transportation funding, Department of Homeland Security funding, and he just backed down and threw in the towel when it came to victims of crime acts. Voka funding. So I think he'll try again. On February 1st, he was supposed to try to withhold funding from sanctuary jurisdictions again. February 1st has come and passed, but we remain vigilant and on
只能听从联邦政府的差遣，而根据第十修正案和支出条款的规则，这是绝对不允许发生的。因此，在过去一年里，针对这种把戏，针对特朗普政府企图以“加州必须按照他希望的方式参与移民执法”作为前提条件来扣留加州应得资金的做法，我们已经四次击败了特朗普政府。我们在交通部资金、国土安全部资金的问题上击败了他，当涉及犯罪受害者法案（Voka）资金时，他也只能退缩并举手投降。所以我认为他还会再试一次。2月1日，他本应再次尝试扣留庇护司法管辖区的资金。2月1日已经过去，但我们仍然保持警惕，并随时
high alert to see what he might do because this is something he did in Trump 1.0. We did it again in 2.0. We think he'll do it again, but we are on very solid constitutional ground, and we have won every time he's tried to do this, and we believe we will win again if he tries again. Yeah, I just want to step back for a moment and just tie these things together. You know, you've mentioned that the federal government can't commandeer or force the states to do things. That's the reason of the Supreme Court's interpretation of the Tenth Amendment. Congress can certainly offer funds to the states and incentivize them, but at some point, if it's too much, it's too coercive, it actually violates a Tenth Amendment principle.
保持高度警惕，看他可能会做什么，因为这是他在特朗普 1.0 时代做过的事。我们在 2.0 时代又经历了一次。我们认为他会再次这样做，但我们拥有非常稳固的宪法依据，而且每次他试图这样做时我们都赢了，我们相信如果他再试一次，我们还会赢。是的，我只是想退后一步，把这些事情串联起来。你知道，你提到过联邦政府不能指挥或强迫各州做事情。这就是最高法院对第十修正案解释的依据。国会当然可以向各州提供资金并激励它们，但在某种程度上，如果金额过大、强制性太强，它实际上就违反了第十修正案的原则。
So there's a lot of robust principles in the Constitution about saying states have certain prerogatives and rights that the federal government can't touch. So there's a whole set of cases here, as you mentioned, that make that clear. Now, one thing of interest is right after Renee Good was killed, the state of Minnesota filed a lawsuit in federal court against the Trump administration, arguing that the administration was violating the state's 10th Amendment rights. And your office filed an amicus or a front of the court brief. And the whole lawsuit is premised on the idea that this is a big 10th Amendment problem. And I wonder if you had any thoughts about like what exactly is that issue there. Why is the surreuth? in Minneapolis and in other cities in Minnesota, why was that violating the Constitution? Yeah, Minnesota and Illinois both brought cases of this nature asserting Tenth Amendment claims against the federal government. And the cases we have talked about already involved sort of the coercive use of funding, attaching conditions to the funding and trying and attempts
因此，宪法中有许多强有力的原则，表明各州拥有联邦政府无法干涉的某些特权和权利。正如你所提到的，这里有一整套判例明确了这一点。现在，有一件有趣的事情是，在雷妮·古德被杀后不久，明尼苏达州在联邦法院对特朗普政府提起诉讼，辩称该行政当局侵犯了该州的第十修正案权利。你们办公室提交了一份法庭之友简报。整个诉讼的前提是，这是一个重大的第十修正案问题。我想知道你对那里究竟存在什么问题有什么看法。为什么明尼阿波利斯以及明尼苏达州其他城市的搜查——为什么这违反了宪法？是的，明尼苏达州和伊利诺伊州都提出了此类案件，针对联邦政府主张第十修正案权利。我们之前讨论过的案件涉及某种程度上对资金的强制性使用，将条件附加到资金上并尝试
to withhold, you know, huge amounts, billions of dollars with the funding. And that becomes coercive at some point and becomes compulsion. There's other ways you can coerce or compel. You can, you know, you can, it could be a command of control where you order or mandate, or it can be a militarized occupation of your state until you give in and say, I'll no longer be a sanctuary state. And, you know, the chaos, the constitutional rights violations, the deaths, the killings of American citizens. And the U.S. Attorney General Pam Bondi wrote a letter. that said some of this in it and sent it to Minnesota and said, you know, we can withdraw and deescalate if you do these things that you're already beating us on court on that we tried to do
扣留数额巨大的资金，价值数十亿美元的资金。在某个时刻，这就会变成强制性的，并演变成逼迫。还有其他方法可以进行胁迫或逼迫。你可以，你知道，这可能是一种指挥控制，你下达命令或强制要求，或者它可能是对你所在州的军事化占领，直到你妥协并表示：我不再是一个庇护州。而且，你知道，混乱、宪法权利的侵犯、死亡、美国公民的遇害。美国总检察长帕姆·邦迪写了一封信，信中提到了其中的一些内容，并将其发给明尼苏达州，说，你知道，如果你做这些我们在法庭上已经占了上风、而我们曾试图在其他方面做到的事情，我们可以撤退并缓和局势。
in other ways. But it was coercion of another type, not necessarily financial, but imposing a unprecedented and militarized occupation in the form of Operation Metro Surge until sanctuary policies were withdrawn. And also there was also a equal sovereignty claim. And equal sovereignty is the idea that all states are on equal footing in the eyes of the federal government, that they should all be treated the same. Trump doesn't treat all states the same. He targets and focuses on and attacks Democratic states, blue states. He says it. It's not a conclusion or an inference. It's what he says explicitly he will do. So those arguments were advanced in the Minnesota case and in the Illinois case, the Northern District of Illinois has not yet issued any opinions.
但这是另一种类型的胁迫，不一定是财务方面的，而是以“都会激增行动”（Operation Metro Surge）的形式实施前所未有的军事化占领，直到庇护政策被撤销。此外，还有一个关于主权平等的诉求。主权平等是指在联邦政府眼中，所有州都处于同等地位，它们都应受到平等的对待。特朗普并没有平等对待所有州。他将民主党州、蓝州作为目标、焦点和攻击对象。他是这么说的。这并不是推论或推断。这就是他明确表示自己会做的事。因此，这些论点在明尼苏达州的案件和伊利诺伊州的案件中被提出，伊利诺伊州北区联邦地区法院尚未就此发表任何意见。
In the Minnesota case, at the preliminary injunction stage, Minnesota's arguments were not accepted by the court at this point. So we'll see what happens next. There's more of the case to occur and more stages than it left. But we think these are important positions to stake out by the states who are being coerced in different ways by the Trump administration. And we're in unprecedented territory. The Trump administration is doing things. We haven't seen before trying to coerce, trying to compel using different tactics and different levers. This is kind of what Trump does. He likes to use leverage. He sees money as leverage. He also sees force as leverage. He sees military occupation as leverage. See LA in June of this year when the National Guard was unlawfully
在明尼苏达州的案件中，在初步禁令阶段，法院目前尚未接受明尼苏达州的论点。所以我们将拭目以待接下来会发生什么。案件还有更多的审理环节，还有好几个阶段没有走完。但我们认为，这些是由遭到特朗普政府各种方式胁迫的各州所必须坚守的重要立场。我们正处于前所未有的领域。特朗普政府正在做一些我们以前没见过的事情，试图通过不同的策略和杠杆进行胁迫和逼迫。这有点像特朗普的行事风格。他喜欢利用筹码。他将资金视为筹码。他也将武力视为筹码。他将军事占领视为筹码。看看今年 6 月的洛杉矶，当时国民警卫队被非法
federalized and deployed. And the Marines were sent in as well. And then he did that in another blue city, Portland, and another blue city, Washington, D.C., and another blue city, Chicago, while berating them about their alleged public safety issues and complaining about their policies of, you know, sanctuary, which they have every right to adopt. I wonder if we could turn to another place of constitutional conflict for the states, and specifically the abortion context. You know, after the Supreme Court overturned the constitutionally protected right to an abortion in 2022, states were, free to do whatever they wanted. So some states, of course, severely restricted or even banned abortion
联邦化并进行部署。海军陆战队也被派了进去。然后他在另一个蓝城波特兰、另一个蓝城华盛顿特区以及另一个蓝城芝加哥也这样做了，同时严厉指责他们所谓的公共安全问题，并抱怨他们采取庇护政策——而他们完全有权采取这些政策。我想知道我们是否可以转向各州面临宪法冲突的另一个领域，具体来说是堕胎的背景。你知道，在最高法院于 2022 年推翻了宪法保护的堕胎权之后，各州就可以自由做它们想做的事。因此，一些州当然严格限制甚至禁止了堕胎，
and others provided protections for access to legal abortion. So for instance, Texas has banned nearly all abortions. So a medical provider cannot provide a legal abortion inside the state of Texas. But of course, the availability of abortion medications and telemedicine means that a doctor in New York or California can provide medication to a patient who is living in Texas without ever having set foot in Texas. Now, some states, including Texas, have decided to go after some of these doctors who have helped women obtain abortions within their states, even though the doctors have never entered Texas or Louisiana. And of course, there is another aspect of the Constitution that's the full faith and credit clause of Article 4. And the general idea here, of course, is that every state should
而另一些州则为获取合法堕胎提供了保护。例如，得克萨斯州几乎禁止了所有堕胎。因此，医疗服务提供者不能在得克萨斯州境内提供合法的堕胎服务。但是，当然，堕胎药物和远程医疗的普及意味着，纽约或加利福尼亚的一名医生可以向居住在得克萨斯州的患者提供药物，而这位医生甚至从未踏足过得克萨斯州。现在，包括得克萨斯州在内的一些州已经决定追究其中一些医生的责任，这些医生曾帮助该州女性获得堕胎服务，尽管这些医生从未进入过得克萨斯州或路易斯安那州。当然，宪法中还有另一个方面，即第四条的“充分信任与信用条款”。这里的总体理念当然是，每个州都应该
keep their own courts open to the laws and judgments of the other states. And California does provide access to reproductive health and legal abortion. So what is the state doing here to balance protecting these rights within the state, but then also not crossing the line in terms of constitutional requirements that state should respect each other's laws and proceedings? Well, in that regard, we are asserting ourselves in California with respect to our state's rights to decide that abortion is safe and, and legal. We've even enshrined it in our state constitution here. The people of our state
对其他州的法律和判决保持各自的法院开放。加利福尼亚州确实提供了获得生殖健康和合法堕胎的途径。那么，州政府在此采取了什么行动，来平衡保护州内的这些权利，同时又不在宪法要求（即各州应尊重彼此的法律和诉讼程序）方面越界？嗯，在这方面，我们加利福尼亚州正在坚决维护我们州决定堕胎是安全且合法的权利。我们甚至将这一点写入了我们州的宪法之中。我们州的人民
decided that there is a constitutional right to an abortion and contraception. We've created laws that provide the ability for patients to seek and receive and providers to provide safe and legal abortions in California and also prevented attempts from other states to sort of engage in long-arm civil and criminal liability actions, trying to reach into California and because something that we find completely legal and that is safe in California, but they disagree in their state that there's liability in that other state. So we've put up a number of different guardrails and protections and legal safe havens in California. And we think that is all within our rights to do so, and that our decisions here, the court's decisions here,
认为堕胎和避孕是一项宪法权利。我们制定了相关法律，为患者在加州寻求、接受安全合法的堕胎以及医疗提供者提供此类服务创造了能力，同时也阻止了其他州试图进行长臂民事和刑事责任诉讼的企图——试图将手伸进加州，因为我们在加州认为完全合法且安全的事情，在他们看来在那个州却要承担责任。因此，我们在加州设立了许多不同的护栏、保护措施和法律避风港。我们认为这完全在我们的权利范围内，我们在这是作出的决定、法院在此作出的决定，
deserve full faith and credit and should be honored by other states. So we don't see any constitutional problems with our robust, lawful commitment to safe and legal abortion in California. And that includes things like sort of refusing to hand over information about doctors who might have provided such information and help to use patients within states that have severely restricted or banned abortion. Is that right? Yeah, there are some prohibitions on, for example, a corporation, like let's say Apple or Google getting a subpoena from an out-of-state entity about a medical procedure abortion
理应享有充分的信任与信用，并应受到其他州的尊重。因此，对于我们在加州坚定、合法地致力于安全和合法堕胎的做法，我们不认为存在任何宪法问题。这包括诸如拒绝交出关于那些可能在严重限制或禁止堕胎的州内向患者提供此类信息和帮助的医生的信息之类的事情。是这样吗？是的，有一些禁令，例如，像苹果或谷歌这样的公司收到来自州外实体关于医疗堕胎程序的传票时，
that is completely legal in California. it's a legal and private medical procedure and there's no appropriate basis for that information to be sought by an out-of-state entity. And so there are protections in place for that. Basically, we are protecting anything in California that is lawful in California from any type of exposure to civil or criminal liability from someone outside of the state who sees it differently. Many of the lawsuits that your office has been involved with against Trump are part of this multi-state coalitions of Democratic attorneys general. Apart from just reacting to actions from administration, like, have you been in planning mode? How do you coordinate? How do you talk to each other?
这在加州是完全合法的。这是一项合法且私密的医疗程序，州外实体没有适当的依据来索取此类信息。因此，对此有相应的保护措施。基本上，我们在加州保护任何在加州合法的事物，免受任何来自州外、持不同看法的人的民事或刑事责任追究。你们办公室参与的针对特朗普的许多诉讼，都是由民主党总检察长跨州联盟发起的。除了对行政当局的行动做出反应之外，你们是否一直在进行规划？你们是如何协调的？你们是如何彼此沟通的？
This, you know, new fraternity of people, paternity sorority, collection of people, is really on new ground. And how are you working together in a way that's different? It's a coalition of co-equals. We are all a independent. executive in our sovereign states. No one's the boss of anybody else or all each other's peers. We work together by choice deliberately and intentionally because we believe that we together can create something that's greater and stronger and more powerful than the sum of our parts when we come together as a whole. And we have been planning and talking and strategizing and
这个，你知道的，由新一代人组成的兄弟会、姐妹会、人群集合，确实是在一片未知的土地上。你们是如何以一种与以往不同的方式共同工作的？这是一个平等者组成的联盟。我们都是我们主权国内独立的行政长官。没有人是谁的老板，我们都是彼此的同僚。我们通过选择、刻意且有意地共同工作，因为我们相信，当我们作为一个整体走到一起时，我们共同创造的东西将比我们各部分的总和更伟大、更强大、更有力量。我们一直在进行规划、讨论、制定战略，并且
preparing since before Trump was elected. Knowing that we couldn't guarantee he wouldn't be, and also knowing that we owed our constituents readiness, preparedness, that we could not be caught flat-footed, that we couldn't, you know, if Trump got elected, say, hey, we were all hoping Kamala would get elected, and now we don't know what to do. We had to know. And so we listened to everything he said on the campaign trail,
在特朗普当选之前就一直在做准备。因为我们知道我们无法保证他不会当选，同时也知道我们欠选民以就绪状态和防范意识，我们不能被打个措手不及，我们不能说，你知道的，如果特朗普当选了，我们就说：“天哪，我们都希望卡玛拉当选，现在我们不知道该怎么办了。”我们必须做到心中有数。因此，我们聆听了他在竞选期间发表的一切言论，
his promises, even if it might be bluff or it might be bluster, we took a matter's word and assumed he was going to do it. And he handed to us a written document that told us what he would do. Project 2025. And we reviewed that and looked at all of the plans therein and assumed he was going to engage in trying to manifest those plans. And my team and our collective teams were tasked with being ready for all of the above. Be ready for the Insurrection Act. Be ready for the Comstock Act. Be ready for all of these sort of fringe theory approaches to seizing power that's not theirs in the quote unquote unitary executive and attacking our states
他的承诺，即使那可能是虚张声势，我们也当真并假定他会这么做。他给我们交出了一份书面文件，告诉了我们会做什么：《2025 计划》。我们审查了该文件，研究了其中的所有计划，并假设他会着手将这些计划付诸实施。我的团队和我们的集体团队的任务就是为上述所有情况做好准备。为《叛乱法》做好准备。为《康斯托克法》做好准备。为所有这些边缘理论方法做好准备——那些试图夺取不属于他们的、所谓的“单一行政权”，并攻击我们的州、
and our progress and our policies and our people and our values. So, you know, there are some things that haven't had to come to pass yet. We've been ready to address for months. We don't want them to come to pass. But if they do, all we have to do is dot the eyes, cross the T's, press print and file our complaint, and we believe we'll win because we've thought about it and we prepared. And among our, there are 24 Democratic attorneys general when Trump was inaugurated. There were 23. The Virginia AG flipped from red to blue in the election in November of last year. And we communicate every week. We meet often. We pick up the phones regularly. Our staffs are in regularly set meetings to communicate, plan, prepare. We are flagging issues that
我们的进步、我们的政策、我们的人民和我们的价值观的企图。所以，你知道，有些事情还没有发生。我们几个月来一直准备应对。我们不希望它们发生。但如果它们发生了，我们要做的就是点上句号、画好十字、按打印键并提交起诉状，我们相信我们会赢，因为我们已经思考过了并做好了准备。在我们的行列中，特朗普就职时有 24 位民主党总检察长。当时有 23 位。去年 11 月的选举中，弗吉尼亚州总检察长从红变蓝。我们每周都进行交流。我们经常开会。我们定期通电话。我们的工作人员定期举行会议进行沟通、规划、准备。我们标记出
we see in our states, asking the other states if they're experiencing the same thing. things and deciding where we file a lawsuit, what claims we file on, what our injury is, and how we protect our people and our states from these unlawful actions. So there has been consistent contact, communication, strategizing, planning, preparing since before Trump was elected until today. And now, you know, we're 55 lawsuits in in California and, you know, a really strong record of success. And we're ready for whatever comes. Got a full tank of gas. of energy, ready to roll. Hope that this president might decide, hey, maybe it's a good idea to follow my oath and comply with the Constitution and not trample on it and not look over longingly
我们在各州看到的问题，询问其他州是否也在经历同样的事情，并决定我们在哪里提起诉讼、我们以什么罪名起诉、我们的损害是什么，以及我们如何保护我们的人民和各州免受这些非法行动的侵害。因此，自特朗普当选前到今天，一直存在着持续的接触、沟通、制定战略、规划和准备。现在，你知道的，我们在加州提起了 55 起诉讼，你知道的，有着非常强劲的成功记录。我们已经为即将发生的一切做好了准备。油箱加满了能量，随时准备出发。希望这位总统可能会决定：嘿，也许遵守我的誓言、遵守宪法、不践踏宪法、不贪婪地斜视
at Congress and say, hey, I'd love to have the power of the purse. I'm just going to start using it. Or looking over at our courts and saying, they can't review my actions. Or looking down at the states and saying they don't have any sovereign rights, they need to do what I say, and that he'll comply with the Constitution. But that's probably a lost hope. And in the meantime, time we stay ready and we stay prepared. What are you most worried about that might happen in the coming year from the administration? This is an election year. So I think the integrity of our elections is critical. They're safe. They're secure. They're accurate. They're reliable in California. And across the country, Trump has attacked them time and time again. He's tried to use his bully
国会并说“嘿，我很想拥有钱袋子的权力，我要开始使用它了”是个好主意；或者斜视我们的法院并说“他们无权审查我的行动”；或者俯视各州并说它们没有任何主权权利，它们需要按我说的去做；并且他会遵守宪法。但这可能是一个破灭的希望。与此同时，我们随时保持就绪和准备状态。对于行政当局在接下来的一年里可能做的事情，你最担心的是什么？今年是选举年。所以我认为我们选举的完整性至关重要。在加州以及全国各地，它们是安全、稳妥、准确且可靠的。特朗普一次又一次地攻击它们。他试图利用他的讲坛优势，
pulpit and the fact that he has the biggest megahorn on the planet to try to erode trust in our elections by even to this day claiming that he won the 2020 election after people heard his own voice asked the secretary of state of Georgia to find him 11,000 plus votes to find them. You don't find votes. The votes are cast. You count votes. And he recently sent law enforcement into Georgia to try to support this conspiracy theory that is a figment of his imagination. And that's a dangerous mental state for the president of the United States to be in. The fact that he seems to think that if he wins the election, it was fair and reliable. And if he loses the election, it was rigged.
利用他拥有地球上最大扩音器的现实，试图侵蚀人们对我们选举的信任——甚至直到今天，在人们听到他自己的声音要求佐治亚州国务卿为他“找出”11,000 多张选票之后，他依然声称自己赢得了 2020 年大选。选票是不能“找”出来的。选票是投出来的。选票是数出来的。他最近派执法人员前往佐治亚州，试图支持这个纯属他凭空想象的阴谋论。作为美利坚合众国的总统，这是一种危险的精神状态。他似乎认为，如果他赢得选举，那就是公平可靠的；而如果他输了选举，那就是被操纵的。
And he's even maintained that he's won the election multiple times in Minnesota. And there has been court cases and other tribunals that have determined that there's no basis to any of this. And the polls show that he's going to get beat in the midterms. and that the house will flip. So his conspiracy theory is on elections, plus his increased desperation caused by reflected in the polls and how people in America are thinking about him and are unfavorable towards his policies and approach
他甚至在明尼苏达州多次坚称自己赢得了大选。已经有法庭案件和其他法庭判定这一切都没有任何依据。民意调查显示，他将在中期选举中落败，众议院将会易主。因此，他对选举的阴谋论，加上民意调查反映出的日益增长的绝望情绪，以及美国民众对他的看法、对他政策和方法的反感，
and are going to be supporting Democrats in the next election and his willingness to militarize American cities. Those are a dangerous combination. And so I worry about the possibility of federalized national Guard at or near polling stations. I worry about the Marines at or near polling stations. I worry about attempts to use the U.S. Postal Service, a federal, part of the federal government to interfere with vote by mail ballots that are cast. I worry about the people's voice not being heard and being stepped on by an unlawful president who's violating their rights.
以及他们在下次选举中将支持民主党，还有他愿意将美国城市军事化——这些是一个危险的组合。因此，我担心在投票站或附近部署联邦化国民警卫队的可能性。我担心投票站或附近出现海军陆战队。我担心有人企图利用美国邮政局（联邦政府的一个组成部分）来干扰通过邮寄投票的选票。我担心人民的声音听不见，并被一个侵犯他们权利的非法总统踩在脚下。
And so that just fuels me more to fight harder. I'm also concerned we haven't seen sort of the other shoe drop, if you will, on attacks on abortion. We were prepared for a weaponization of the Comstock Act to try to stop the mailing of medication abortion. We haven't seen that yet, but we're prepared and ready. if it happens. And those are some of the things that are top of mind. We haven't seen the Insurrection Act
所以这只会助长我更猛烈地斗争。我也很担心，关于攻击堕胎的“另一只靴子”还没有落地。我们已经准备好应对将《康斯托克法》武器化以试图阻止邮寄堕胎药物的做法。我们还没有看到这一点，但如果它发生，我们已经做好了准备。这些都是我们最关心的一些事情。我们还没有看到《叛乱法》
be invoked and hope we never will. But he has bandied it about and sort of dangled it out there and suggested he might use it multiple times. And we have closed the door on his ability to use 10 U.S.C. 12406. That's the federal statute that he relied on to deploy
被援引，希望永远也不会看到。但他一直在谈论它，并在某种程度上将其悬在空中，暗示他可能会多次使用它。我们已经关闭了他利用《美国法典》第 10 篇第 12406 条的能力。那是他赖以部署
National Guard, federalized National Guard to L.A., to Portland, and to Chicago. And with the U.S. Supreme Court case and their recent decision, I believe that door is shut pretty firmly. And so I don't think he will stop in his efforts to use the military as his private roving National Army and police force. And we'll just find other ways. And the Insurrection Act might be that way. Could you talk about the Insurrection Act a little bit? Why is this a weapon that he's threatening to brandish.
国民警卫队（联邦化国民警卫队）到洛杉矶、波特兰和芝加哥的联邦法规。随着美国最高法院的案件及其最近的裁决，我认为那扇门被相当牢固地关上了。因此，我认为他不会停止将军队作为其私人巡回国民军队和警察部队的努力。我们只是会找到其他途径。《叛乱法》可能就是这样一种途径。你能稍微谈谈《叛乱法》吗？为什么这是他威胁要挥舞的武器？
The thing that makes the Insurrection Act different than the other statute that he used, 10 U.S.C. 12-406, and some other statutes is that it's a exception to the Posse Cometatus Act.
《叛乱法》与他使用的其他法规（《美国法典》第 10 篇第 12-406 条）以及其他一些法规的不同之处在于，它是《Posse Comitatus Act》（《地方治安维持法》）的一个例外。
So if he invokes the Insurrection Act and deploys military in American cities, the Posse Cometatis Act, which generally prohibits, the military from engaging in civilian law enforcement, it doesn't apply. The military can engage in civilian law enforcement if the Insurrection Act is invoked. And the president and those around him have a very robust, that's a euphemism. I think it's unlawful and constitutional
因此，如果他援引《叛乱法》并在美国城市部署军队，那么通常禁止军队参与民事执法的《Posse Comitatus Act》将不再适用。如果援引《叛乱法》，军队就可以参与民事执法。总统及其周围的人对此有一种非常强硬的——那是个委婉说法。我认为这是非法的、违宪的——
view of federal power when it comes to the military. I think that they think that they can invoke the Insurrection Act for any reason. or no reason at all, and they can't be questioned. And courts can't stop them, and that it's not reviewable by any judge, even if there's nothing close to an insurrection. And let's be clear, there is nothing close to an insurrection. Anywhere in the United States of America,
关于涉及军队时的联邦权力的看法。我认为他们认为他们可以出于任何原因或根本没有任何原因来援引《叛乱法》，并且他们不会受到质疑。法庭无法阻止他们，任何法官都无法对其进行审查，即使当时的情况与叛乱八竿子打不着。我们要明确一点，美利坚合众国的任何地方都没有任何接近叛乱的情况，
there's no basis, not even close, to lawfully invoke the Insurrection Act. But the president wants the power. That's what he seeks. And if he says there's an insurrection, he likes the power that comes with it and the exception to the Posse Cometatis Act and the ability to move the military into blue cities.
没有任何依据——甚至连边都沾不上——去合法援引《叛乱法》。但总统想要权力。这正是他所追求的。如果他说发生了叛乱，他喜欢随之而来的权力、《Posse Comitatus Act》的例外情况，以及将军队开进蓝城的权力。
And that's why the threshold is so high that there has to be an actual insurrection. For 10 U.S.C. 12-406, there had to be an invasion or a rebellion or an inability to execute the laws with the, they call it the regular forces in that statute. High thresholds, these are emergency powers, exigent powers, powers to rarely
这就是为什么门槛如此之高，必须发生真正的叛乱。对于《美国法典》第 10 篇第 12-406 条，必须发生入侵、叛乱，或者用该法规中所谓的“常规部队”无法执行法律的情况。门槛很高，这些是紧急权力、紧迫权力、很少有
are there facts on the ground that justify them. But there's a saying that emergency powers beget emergencies and that the executive branch sees an emergency everywhere they look, not because there's actually an emergency, but because they like the power if there were an emergency. So that's why Stephen Miller is saying everything's an invasion, everything is a rebellion, everything's an emergency. Not because it is.
地面事实证明其合理性的权力。但有一句俗语说，紧急权力会滋生紧急情况，行政部门在他们所看到的一切地方都看到了紧急情况，不是因为真的有紧急情况，而是因为如果发生了紧急情况，他们喜欢那种权力。这就是为什么斯蒂芬·米勒说一切都是入侵，一切都是叛乱，一切都是紧急情况。不是因为它是。
It's not. common sense people can see it's not. They just want the power. Well, Attorney General Rob Bonta, thank you so much for taking time with talking with us, and we really enjoyed our conversation. It was wonderful.
事实并非如此。有常识的人都能看出事实并非如此。他们只是想要权力。好吧，总检察长罗布·邦塔，非常感谢你抽空与我们交谈，我们真的很享受这次谈话。太棒了。
I'll talk to you. My pleasure. Thanks, Roman. Thanks, Elizabeth. Join us next month for Article 5, which lays out the process to amend the Constitution. The 99% invisible breakdown
回聊。不客气。谢谢罗曼。谢谢伊丽莎白。下个月请加入我们，收听《第五条》，该条规定了修改宪法的程序。本期由 99% Invisible 团队为您呈现的关于宪法的深度解析
of the Constitution is produced by Isabel Angel, edited by committee, music by Swan Real, mixed by Martine Gonzalez. Kathy 2 is our executive producer, Kurt Colsted is the digital director, Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Barube, Jason de Leon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Leigh, Bosch Madon,
由伊莎贝尔·安杰尔（Isabel Angel）制作，委员会编辑，音乐由斯旺·里尔（Swan Real）创作，马蒂恩·冈萨雷斯（Martine Gonzalez）混音。凯西·图（Kathy Tu）是我们的执行制片人，库尔特·科尔斯特ッド（Kurt Colsted）是数字总监，德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）是我们的高级编辑。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Barube）、杰森·德莱昂（Jason de Leon）、埃姆特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、薇薇安·李（Vivian Leigh）、博世·马登（Bosch Madon）、
Joe Rosenberg, Kelly Prime, Jacob Medina Gleason, Talon and Rain Stradley, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. The art for this series was created by Aaron Nestor. We are part of the Serious XM Podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. in beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show on all the usual social media sites as well as our own Discord server, where we have fun discussion that's about constitutional law, but architecture about movies, music, all kinds of good stuff.
乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、凯利·普赖姆（Kelly Prime）、雅各布·梅迪纳·格利森（Jacob Medina Gleason）、泰隆和雷恩·斯特拉德利（Talon and Rain Stradley），以及我，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。99% Invisible 的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作。本系列的艺术作品由亚伦·内斯特（Aaron Nestor）创作。我们是 SiriusXM 播客家族的一部分，总部现在位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的潘多拉大楼以北六个街区。您可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站上找到本节目，以及我们自己的 Discord 服务器，我们在那里就宪法法律、电影和音乐的架构等各种好玩的话题进行有趣的讨论。
You can find a link to the Discord server as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以在 99PI.org 上找到 Discord 服务器的链接以及 99PI 以往的每一期节目。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。